nous retrouvons donc ce matin pour une
audition commune consacrée aux modalités
de sortie des aides aux entreprises
une nouvelle étape est franchie
aujourd'hui dans la levée progressive
des mesures de restriction avec la
réouverture de nombreux lieux publics et
le report de l'heure du couvre-feu
notamment la semaine dernière le
ministre de l'économie des finances de
la relance sur bruno le maire a indiqué
devant notre commission que le projet de
loi de finances rectificative est un
texte sortie de crise et de transition
afin de revenir à la normale ajoutant
qu'il fallait sortir du quoi qu'il en
coûte de manière progressive et adaptée
selon ses mots
d'un point de vue économique que nous
abordons une phase difficile va alors
pas plus difficile que celle que nous
avons connue il ya un an mais difficile
la reprise révélant paradoxalement les
fragilités des entreprises
du coup la question est double il s'agit
d'une part de préciser le calendrier les
modalités de la sortie des aides de
soutien autant qu'on puisse le faire et
d'autre part d'envisager les éventuels
relais qui pourraient être requis pour
certaines entreprises particulièrement
fragilisé le projet de loi de finances
rectificative présenté la semaine
dernière n'apporte qu'une réponse très
partiel ce normal sur la façon dont le
gouvernement entend opérer la transition
entre un soutien large en trésorerie un
accompagnement complémentaires et
ciblées en solvabilité
le 1er juin dernier quelques jours le
gouvernement a présenté un plan d'action
beaucoup plus large sur l'accompagnement
des entreprises en sortie de crise et
c'est ce sujet là qui nous intéresse le
plus c'est de manière que je vous
l'indiquais la plus comment dire la plus
précise possible c'est à dire encore un
peu dans les détails sur la façon de
faire comment on appréhende
cette phase qui est particulièrement
complexe c'est pourquoi pour faire le
point sur ces questions nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir ce matin quatre
intervenants que je remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
monsieur jérôme fournel directeur
général des finances publiques
monsieur hery lacourrège directeur
général des services à l'économie et du
réseau de la banque de france
monsieur christophe beaux les acteurs
général du mouvement des entreprises de
france
dis plutôt du medef monsieur william
noun président du centre d'information
sur la prévention des difficultés des
entreprises au plan national
je rappelle que cette audition est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat et qu'elle est suivie
également par certains de nos collègues
par visioconférence quand vous voyez ici
on a donc deux places relativement
limitée sans plus tarder je vais céder
donc la parole à monsieur jérôme fournel
pour un propos liminaire
on lui donnera quelques minutes
peut-être de plus qu'aux autres dans la
mesure où s'il doit nous parler du plan
j'ai peur que la synthèse vous savez la
faire mais tout de même
et sinon lors de grandeur c'est au tour
de dix minutes de manière à laisser
après vous avez toujours un temps de
questions qui permet de revenir de
manière plus précise sur tel ou tel
sujet donc évidemment monsieur fonelle
vous ne parlerez évidemment de
l'évolution des mesures de soutien aux
entreprises mises en oeuvre par des jets
fip mais aussi donc des grands axes du
plan d'action gouvernemental en cours de
déploiement
comme j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de
le faire le 1er juin
je profite de cette table ronde pour
saluer devant mes collègues l'action et
tout particulièrement la réactivité de
la dgesip
sous votre autorité pour la mise en
oeuvre du plan de sickert je tombe le
veut d'ailleurs que la femme qui démarre
aujourd'hui connaissent finalement le
même succès dans son implémentation
comme diraient les américains jusque
plus que les français que dans son
développement
voilà je vous donne je suis directeur la
parole tout de suite merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
je vais très essayé de tenir le timing
évoquée par le président et puis ensuite
naturellement avec
mes collègues ici présents et répondre
essayé d'entrer dans les détails
nécessaires peut être un point de départ
c'est effectivement ce que rappelait le
président l'instant la mobilisation de
la dgesip pendant la crise qui a été
très forte
il ya eu je faisais le bilan du nombre
de dispositifs de mesure de
bienveillance fiscales qui ont été
prises pendant la crise impôts par un
pot et qui ne sont pas d'ailleurs
terminée puisqu'on continue à avoir des
mesures de report d'élargissement des
modulations d'impôt etc
on a plus d'une cinquantaine donc je
dirais on a eu 1 du travail de dentelle
si je puis dire pour adapter la les
dispositions fiscales et qui ont existé
pendant la crise et je rajoute que par
ailleurs on avait des dispositifs c'est
le cas avec le prélèvement à la source
et les acomptes contemporain notamment
pour les indépendants des dispositifs
qui s'adaptait je dirais à la demande
par ailleurs des entreprises à la
réalité de leur situation économique et
qui pouvaient eux mêmes modules
naturellement il ya eu toute la mise en
place du fonds de solidarité qui n'est
absolument pas terminé puisque à l'heure
où je parle sur le mois au titre de
l'indemnisation du mois d'avril
nous sommes encore en train de payer des
demandes et nous sommes à près de 3
milliards de milliards 8
voilà le fonds de solidarité est en
train de franchir ces jours ci les 30
milliards de décaissement des aides aux
entreprises faut se dire et représenter
les montants que cela représente
on est je sais pas si on a déjà franchi
les 30 milliards ou si c'est demain mais
on est tout proche
de ce montant la troisième
danse est effectivement toute l'action
et qu'on va retrouver en sortie de crise
qui est celle des structures sur le
territoire notamment l'écho défis qui
sont les organismes qui est sur le
territoire rassemble les parties
prenantes et économique autour à la fois
du préfet qui préside le défi et de son
secrétariat permanent et qui est
incarnée par l'agefiph mais avec nos
amis de la banque de france avec
naturellement les urssaf et avec
d'autres acteurs dont on reparlera dans
un instant et ces structures là alors
elles ont enregistré une multiplication
par trois des saisines pendant la crise
curiosité c'est que là où d'habitude
vieri à une translation entre ce qui se
passe du côté déco défi et ce qui se
passe ensuite en prise en charge des
dettes fiscales et sociales via la
conférence des chefs de services
financiers ce qu'on appelle la ccsn
président et pour le coup par le
directeur départemental des finances
publiques et qui rassemble au fond les
créanciers publics et bien au contraire
du côté de la ccsf le nombre de dossiers
par rapport à une moyenne normale a été
plutôt divisée par deux donc on avait en
réalité un niveau d'attention et de
surveillance qui était très fort mais
une situation des entreprises sur le
plan financier qui ne se traduisait pas
par des défaillances et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'on retrouve y compris dans les
sujets de défaillances d'entreprises
avec des statistiques de défaillance
d'entreprises qui ont été pendant
l'année 2020 et début 2000 21
extrêmement faible
la sortie de crise elle se présente
comment elles se présentent de deux
manières d'une part j'ai dit on est
encore loin d'avoir totalement épuisé
aux munitions de crise et on l'a évoqué
le gouvernement est en train de prendre
les décrets qui vont permettre de faire
cette sortie des dispositifs d'urgence
sur des logiques un peu en paliers
progressive pour éviter d'avoir un
retrait trop rapide des dispositifs de
relance notamment du fonds de solidarité
avec des logiques de faire perdurer le
font à la fois sur le mois de mai on va
sortir demain pour ne rien vous cacher
le décret le dispositif pendant le
formulaire d'indemnisation au titre du
mois de mai le guichet sera de nouveau
ouvert dans les mêmes conditions qu
activement que sur le mois d'avril
et parallèlement on va avoir sur les
mois de juin juillet août et donc
pliable encore en juillet août septembre
et bien des dispositifs qui vont
progressivement diminuer qui vont
préserver des dispositifs spécifiques
pour les secteurs qui restent fermées
mais qui pour tous ceux qui réouvre et
on voit mon retard dont je m'excuse
était dû aux bouchons ce qui est un bon
signe d'une certaine manière sur
l'activité économique du pays
eh bien on va avoir quelque chose qui va
être progressif ça naturellement c'est
les dispositifs d'urgence qui vont
progressivement se rétracter et
parallèlement on a effectivement le plan
qui a été annoncé par bruno le maire il
y a une semaine de cela et qui vise au
fond à se dire trois choses la première
c'est qu'il faut que les acteurs qui
sont au contact des entreprises et leurs
représentants bien entendu travaillent
ensemble et que on ne pourra pas être
sur une sortie de crise qui se passe
bien si chacun fait cavalier seul
donc le premier acte je lirai du plan
c'est d'un mètre autour de la table doux
e
ce tu accordes place qui a été formalisé
avec la charte qui a été signé et doux
naturellement l'association pleine et
entière de tous les professionnels qui
gravitent autour des entreprises
bien sûr des acteurs locaux des
collectivités territoriales également et
bien sûr d administration quelle qu'elle
soit et quel que soit leur rôle pourquoi
ça c'est parce qu'au fond il ya une
chose dont on est certaine c'est que on
aura on ne sait pas quand mais il y aura
des entreprises qui seront en difficulté
on peut estimer y compris au vu de la
robustesse de la reprise que lire et ça
sera moins fort que ce que certains
prédisent mais objectivement on n'est
pas là pour faire des paris on est là
pour se préparer et donc l'idée c'est
d'être prêt et pour être prêt il faut
qu'on ait le maximum de signaux qu'on
soit capable de capter et donc le
premier sujet c'est de capter très
largement les signaux et pour ça au
niveau local d'où ce comité
départemental à la sortie de crise qui
incarne cette volonté d'associer la plus
possible des parties prenantes et d'où
les dispositifs que l'on met en place
les rapprochements que l'on fait entre
des outils qui préexistait auparavant
mais qui était un peu séparés et
fragmentée pour avoir le maximum de
capacité de détection des signaux de
fragilité des entreprises
le deuxième temps et ça c'est le rôle de
du conseil départemental à la sortie de
crise qui sera un agent de la direction
générale des finances publiques qui
dirait extrait si je puis dire de son
rôle auprès de duke aux défis qui va
être renforcée
de notre côté à la fois par nos amis de
l'urssaf et puis par des agents propre à
la dg philippe de jouer le rôle
d'orientation au maximum vis-à-vis des
entreprises pour indiquer quel type de
solution est adaptée à elle sur la base
naturellement des informations qui
seront collectés et sur la base
naturellement d'un principe de
confidentialité pour elle parce que
c'est un des sujets dont on va le
retrouver dans le troisième type de
sujets qui sont là les solutions qui ont
été élargies à l'occasion de ce
dispositif de sortie de crise
on a des solutions aux nations qui sont
de nature financière donc on avait déjà
des prêts d'une baisse des prêts
participatifs on avait déjà un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui existait on a
tout ce que j'ai évoquées antérieurement
sur les mesures de report d'échéances
fiscales sociales avec des reports qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 48 mois dans le
cadre de procédures notamment devant la
ccsf et qu'on a allongé de manière en
tout cas très volontariste à 36 mois
même sans procédure auprès des
créanciers publics donc on est vraiment
dans des mesures qui de ce point de vue
là sont très allantes sûrs y compris
l'accompagnement pour des entreprises
qui sont en difficulté
on a tout un champ nouveau qui s'est
mise en place et qui est d'essayer de
maximiser tout ce qui a trait à la
prévention et à l'accompagnement dans
des procédures raccourci de trois mois
notamment dispositif de sortie de crise
pour faire en sorte que les entreprises
n'est pas peur d'aller et de rencontrer
les juges si je puis dire est qu'elle
n'ait pas peur de se faire déposséder de
leurs activités et de leurs
propriété de l'entreprise mais qu'elle
soit bien dans une logique où elles se
disent je vais rencontrer là des gens
qui vont m'aider à remonter sur mon
cheval gt5 avant la crise j'ai connu des
difficultés et on omet y compris avec et
des moins des restructurations de dette
derrière mais on me met en situation de
reprendre mon activité
il ya tout ce pack est là et
naturellement il sait l'intérêt de
l'accord et je vais conclure par là pour
pas être autre l'on sait l'intérêt de
l'accord avec toutes les parties
prenantes c'est qu'au fond tout le monde
accepte de jouer le jeu à la fois bien
sûr la justice d'où d'ailleurs le fait
que la charte qualité aussi nié et la
mission nationale confiée à gérard
poujade elle a été également cosigné par
le garde des sceaux mais plus largement
parce que les acteurs que ce soit les
hadjis mgi que ce soit les gens qui
peuvent avoir un mandat de l'entreprise
pour aller essayer de faire soit de la
conciliation soit de la restructuration
de dette privée est bien tout cela il se
met tout sur la table et il essaye à la
fois de limiter les régimes les montants
qu'il demande le coût des prestations
qu'ils fournissent et donc ils se sont
engagés sur des tarifs intéressants pour
les entreprises parce que là on vise un
tissu d'entreprises très large et très
petit donc par conséquent il faut pas
que ces tarifs là et frey et que surtout
ils se disent je suis dans des mains qui
vont essayer de me sortir avec
l'ensemble des solutions mises sur la
table par les pouvoirs publics
voilà grosso modo en tout cas la
philosophie à défaut d'entrer encore
totalement dans le détail et on en
reparlera probablement sûrement poussé
le directeur
nous en reparlerons dans le détail c'est
même l'objet de cette table ronde et des
questions souvent de mes collègues je le
crois donc maintenant je cède la parole
à monsieur eric lacourrège que j'ai
présentées
total a pour la banque de france qui
pourra revenir sur la situation
financière des entreprises françaises et
leur capacité peut être à tirer parti de
la reprise de l'activité et puis tout
point évidemment en lien avec notre
propos de ce matin monsieur directeur
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général
mesdames messieurs merci beaucoup donc
je me propose de partager donc je vais
essayer d'être succinct même si j'ai
beaucoup d'informations y compris
chiffré à vous donner
mais non je me propose de partager avec
vous quelques réflexions issues des
analystes que la banque de france a pu
mener dans les dernières semaines sur la
situation du tissu productif français et
on a plutôt pas mal avancé sur cette
analyse donc ce sont des informations
qu'on va d'ailleurs étayer dans l'est
dans les prochains mois mais qui sont
déjà relativement
concrètes alors pour ce faire je vais je
me propose de revenir d'abord sur les
sur les premières données tirées de
l'analyse des bilans des entreprises sur
2020 et donc d'aider tendance qui se
dégage sur cette base sur la balance des
risques pour les entreprises françaises
alors on a une situation qui est pour
l'instant relativement sauvegarde et si
l'on puis dire si on peut dire puisque à
ce stade la résilience des entreprises
françaises est plutôt meilleure qu'on
aurait pu qu on aurait pu le croire
grâce aux mesures soutien public dont
dangereux fournel viens de parler et
c'est évidente le dispositif
d'assistance massive qui a été mis en
place dans notre pays et qui d'ailleurs
qui fait partie des records en termes de
volumes et de et de prisma parmi les
pays développés
ce dispositif a permis d'un permis
d'amortir considérablement le choc de
cette crise qu vide d'où une
photographie à ce stade de la situation
des entreprises françaises qui est
plutôt positive mais je parle bien à ce
stade je vais détailler
je détaillerai aussi au jour viendrait
assez rapidement sur les enjeux de
soutien des entreprises donc en sortie
crise et comment on les voit à côté
banque de france puisque c'est un des
indes est un des points importants de
notre notre débat et d'ailleurs je ferai
aussi un petit focus
focus sur ce que la banque de france
peut apporter dans ce dans ce disque
dans ces dispositifs de soutien alors
premier point important dans l'analyse
quelle est la photographie de la santé
financière de nos entreprises au travers
des bilans 2020 des entreprises alors
vous le savez certainement la banque de
france gère une base de données qui
s'appelle fiben le fichier bancaire des
entreprises qui suit la qualité du
financement
des entreprises françaises dans le cadre
d'ailleurs de ses missions fondamentales
de banque centrale puisque cette base
fiben nous sert à la fois pour étayer
certaines missions de politique
monétaire nous sert aussi pour calculer
les ratios prudentiels pour les besoins
de crédit et puis nous sert avant et
avant tout pour conseiller les stades
gestion de crédit dans le financement
des entreprises françaises
alors cette cette base là où on fait le
focus aujourd'hui en termes d'analysé
sur les encours de crédits qui sont
déclarées par les établissements de
crédit à l'ensemble des entreprises et
donc derrière bien sûr on fait le focus
aussi sur les comptes financiers
nous avons produit nous produisons assez
de travail que nous faisons chaque année
une analyse financière individuelle de
toutes les entreprises françaises au
dessus de 750000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires
ça représente une grosse partie du pib
pas l'ensemble puisque bien sûr tpe pme
en dessous on les a pas si je priais
dans notre radar
ceci dit avec ce prisme 750000 euros 2,6
d'affaires est au dessus nous avons une
visibilité assez large de l'état de
l'économie
c'est un thermomètre qui est précieux
mais je vais vous en donner donc
quelques quelques éléments parce que
nous avons une capacité d'établir la
projection de santé financière des
entreprises non seulement de manière
instantanée sur la base du bilan et du
compte de résultat qu'on analyse mais
aussi sur la base d'une analyse
qualitative en projetant sur les
capacité d'honorer les engagements de
chaque entreprise de 1 à 3 ans donc
c'est sûr le futur proche
et donc ça c'est assez précieux en
sortie crise pour voir comment les
entreprises peuvent mais peuvent
négocier peuvent négocier leur sortie de
crise alors sur 2020 la photographie
elle est partielle pour l'instant
puisqu'on a récolté à ce stade
notamment grâce à notre à notre
collaboration avec la dia ce genre les
finances publiques
on a on a en a récolté 123 mille bilan à
fin avril et à fin mai on a récolté un
peu plus de 200 milles bilan 1 200 5000
l'analyse que je vais partager avec vous
elle porte sur la phase janvier à avril
à fin avril en est en train d'actualiser
avec les bilans aurait récolté au mois
de mai en tout cas à fin avril donc sur
100 323 milles bilan je voudrais
partager avec vous quatre tendances
préliminaires qui me semble vraiment
importante
la première si je peux me permettre je
j'enfonce une porte ouverte mais la
crise financière a fortement impacté la
structure la crise
excusez-moi la crise sanitaire a
fortement impacté la structure
financière des entreprises des
entreprises françaises alors on a on a
remarqué que cette crise paradoxalement
c'est peu traduites sur c'est sûr c'est
sur la grande majorité des bilans
convient d'étudier au niveau de
l'activité
parce que la baisse du chiffre
d'affaires telle qu'elle est enregistrée
sur les bilans 2020 donc ce qui retrace
la l'entièreté la crise convient de 2020
la base du fichier de fer est contenu à
hauteur de - 7 % avec aussi une
résidence de la rentabilité dans les
bilans qu'on analyse est pour l'instant
et avec une hausse globale moyenne du
résultat net de + 4 %
tout ça est dû et on vient d'en parler à
l'importance du disque des dispositifs
de soutien publics un financier de
toutes sortes qui ont permis donc de
protéger en tout cas sur l'échantillon
qu'on analyse et encore une fois il va
falloir attendre le reste de l'année
quand on aura récupéré l'ensemble des
bilans mais donc ça c'est un point qui
est remarquable donc
l'effet d'amortisseur se traduit très
directement au niveau des niveaux des
comptes en termes de en termes de shafer
d'euros de rentabilité néanmoins et ça
c'est le point extrême important dans
cette première tendance c'est que le
point de grande vigilance et que bien
entendu nos entreprises voient une
augmentation très significative de leur
endettement et de leur endettement brut
notamment je vais revenir 7 lié au
succès si je puis dire du prêt garanti
par l'état qui ceux qui s'élèvent comme
vous le savez à ce jour à 139 milliards
d'euros d'encours débloqués pour les
entreprises 139 milliards ce qui fait
d'ailleurs de la france
l'un des pays de l' ocde devant
l'empereur en première ligne en termes
de en termes de volumes de prêts
garantis 670 mille entreprises en ont
bénéficié donc c'est pour 6 d'érable
donc là on a tous le prisme de
l'économie française est principalement
d'ailleurs les tpe les pme tant en
nombre c'est 95% des prix ont été
attribués aux tpe pme quand en cours
c'est à peu près 75 % voilà donc cette
première tendance en demi teinte si je
puis dire situation financière
instantanée plutôt positive mais
structurellement une aggravation
l'endettement bien entendu qui est liée
au volume massif de p&g la deuxième
tendance c'est que la déformation des
bilans des entreprises est asymétrique
du côté des actifs
on remarque la majorité des entreprises
étudiées peut quasiment 75 % affichent
une augmentation de leurs traits henry
en particulier les entreprises qui ont
eu recours au pge et donc du côté des
passifs par contre et ça va bien sûr de
pair les dettes financières de moyen
long terme vont fortement augmenter
alors il faut avoir en tête aussi que
cette évolution là va être largement
dépendant de la stratégie de
remboursement des pg e et on sait que à
fin mars 2021 moins de 5% des encours de
pge ont été remboursés et d'ailleurs on
sait aussi quand on interroge les
entreprises sur tous les territoires qui
ont su qu'ils ont souscrit des prêts
yeux que la très grande majorité d'entre
elles annoncent que cp je vois être
convertis reconvertir en dette
amortissable ou bien terme c'est à dire
les entrepreneurs vont profiter du
dispositif d'étalement bien sûr du
remboursement tel qu'il a été prévu par
par les peuples par les textes alors
troisième tendance importante
je voudrais insister là dessus nous
notons une différence marquée en termes
de santé financière entre les secteurs
d'activités divers qui font notre tissu
productif là aussi c'est presque une
évidence parce qu'on en a parlé beaucoup
et on l'a vu dans le déroulement de la
crise et les entreprises qui ont
accumulé de la trésorerie ne sont pas
nécessairement les mêmes que celles qui
ont accumulé des dettes
nous n'avons nous notons et ça c'est un
facteur très important que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont augmenté leur niveau
trésorerie notamment via les pg e à
titre de précaution et donc ça se
traduit dans le volume en valeur absolue
de 13 et de l'évolution de la trésorerie
des entreprises françaises est ce qui
fait aussi bien sûr que si on parle de
dette brute on voit qu'elle a
considérablement augmenté je pourrais
vous redonner les chiffes par contre si
on raisonne en dette nette donc d'être
rude boy - trésorerie
là la situation est relativement plus
contenue on analyse et c'est ça qui est
important de regarder et on est en train
d'affiner cette analyse on sera en
mesure d'ailleurs de 2 d'ici une
quinzaine de jours de diffuser une étude
détaillée là dessus on est en train
d'analyser dans la population des
entreprises qui a vu à la fois son
endettement augmenter et sa trésorerie
baissé parce que c'est ça le secteur à
risque pour notre économie
on est en train d'affiner l'analyse et
de je dirais d'identifier ces
entreprises et donc sur l'ensemble des
autres des entreprises françaises on est
donc sur la base des bilans qu'on
analyse et il faut encore une fois
attendre que les autres bilans nous
arrive pour qu'on était cette analyse on
estime qu'à peu près 13 % des
entreprises sont dans une zone vraiment
à risque et ce sont celles sur
lesquelles il va falloir concentrer nos
effort d'attention et de soutien pour
passer la vague du de la sortie de crise
je pourrais si vous souhaitez y revenir
quatrième tendance
les défaillances d'entreprises jérôme
fournel en a parlé
nous sommes aussi là donc quelque chose
un peu contre intuitif
mais qui est totalement explicable par
l'ampleur des dispositifs de soutien
publics les des faits aux entreprises
sont moins nombreuses d'environ 45% par
rapport à la situation d'avant crise
avant 2019 et donc ça ne préjuge pas de
ce qui va se passer dans les prochains
mois néanmoins ça illustre encore une
fois l'importance du soutien public donc
c'est bien entendu lié à l'ensemble des
dispositifs de soutien dont parlait donc
par les jambes
ces premières tendances donc devront
être devant être confirmés à partir de
mai avec les beaux mais nous allons
pouvoir avoir un recul à la banque de
france sur à peu près 200 milles bilans
d'entreprises qui nous ont remis leur
bilan qu'on aura analysé et donc on va
étayer ces chiffres là nous serons ainsi
en mesure à partir donc sur la balle sur
le sol est donnée de médicine quinzaine
de jours de préciser la population à
risque la population à risque pour nous
elle et quand on regarde notre cotation
dans l'est dans les trois niveaux de
cotation intermédiaires ou la capacité à
respecter les engagements est considéré
comme étant assez faible faible ou
correcte et dans ces trois catégories
leur d'entreprise
donc c'est un sous-ensemble bien sûr de
toutes les entreprises côte on considère
que ces entreprises là ce sont dans
l'oeil du cyclone si je puis dire en
termes de capacité de rebond une sortie
de crise
et c'est sur ces entreprises qui va
falloir qu'on condé pas notre notre
attention voilà alors ce que je voulais
indiqué très rapidement mais ce
président et je veux pas être
monopolisée trop la parole et je
répondrai ensuite à des questions
techniques si vous souhaitez je voudrais
signaler deux choses important nous
avons déployé en parallèle à l'ensemble
des acteurs publics des dispositifs très
fort de soutien aux entreprises le
premier donc bien sûr tout le monde a
entendu parler c'est la médiation du
crédit puisque nous sommes nous sommes
intervenus
avec tous nos directeurs départementaux
qui sont médiateur dans chaque
département pour étudier recueillir les
demandes des chefs d'entreprise qui
n'avait pas eu droit à des financements
bancaires ou quelques refus de leur
banquier
et je voudrais signaler que sur la
médiation du crédit
nous avons multiplié l'an dernier par
quatorze le nombre de nos interventions
nous sommes passés en croisière à peu
près à 1000 dossiers traités par an à
14000 dossier avec un taux de succès de
la médiation donc en fait d'attribution
d'entrée par le banquier in fine et
suite à notre intervention de 52%
donc ça a été ça a été plutôt une
opération très très très importants
essentiellement du pge c'était sujet de
l'année dernière donc ça la médiation
continue cette année à un rythme assez
élevé
nous avons traité plusieurs milliers de
dossiers déjà en début d'année et donc
on voit très bien que le sujet de la
sortie de crise reste critique en terme
de financement pour de nombreuses
entreprises et qui viennent nous voir
deuxième point les gens n'arrêterait l'a
ensuite je voudrais aussi signaler que
nous avons mis à disposition des chefs
d'entreprise on a fait pas mal de
publicité là dessus un service de
soutien qui s'appelle le correspondant
tpe pme dans chaque département nous
avons une ou plusieurs personnes dans
chaque département qui est à l'écouté
des chefs d'entreprise à la fois pour
faire des diagnostics financier
individualisé à partir d'outils
d'analysé financière pour aider les
entrepreneurs à y voir clair sur leur
trajectoire et aussi pour orienter ces
entrepreneurs vers l'ensemble des
interlocuteurs delà de la sphère
financière économique ou judiciaires
d'ailleurs de manière à leur permettre
de négocier au plus tôt
leur rebond ce président je remercie
merci monsieur le directeur nous nous
allons poursuivre maintenant avec sur le
directeur de du medef en lui d'ailleurs
en lui disant que peut-être nous avons
été collectivement un peu un peu étonné
d'un article du président du medef qui
nous a paru extrêmement optimiste sur la
sortie de crise et sur les difficultés
éventuelles
en tout cas c'était à tonalité générale
ce qu'on peut comprendre quand on veut
d'ailleurs touché l'économie a toujours
un discours plutôt positif à mener mais
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous situer les
choses avec selon un peu là la typologie
d'entreprise les secteurs d'activité en
fait je passe la parole sur cette
question générale
merci monsieur le président je le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
je ne sais pas exactement à quel article
vous faites allusion monsieur le
président parce que mon président mon
faisant s'exprime beaucoup mais j'ai en
tête son interview de ce matin dans les
échos qui donne une tonalité comme vous
dit assez optimiste sur la reprise et
sans doute y at-il derrière cela la
volonté d'accompagner d'encourager les
entreprises mais où il signale aussi un
certain nombre de facteurs de risque en
particulier sur l'emploi c'est à dire la
difficulté pour beaucoup d'entreprises à
trouver des salariés en face de leurs
besoins on pense en particulier à la
restauration hôtellerie est aussi un
deuxième facteur de risque qui est celui
de tensions inflationnistes qu'on voit
réapparaître notamment sur les matières
premières qui peuvent affecter en
particulier le bâtiment on voit ici ou
là des matériaux de construction ont
augmenté de 30% avec des risques parce
que le bâtiment est confrontée à des
contrats qui se chiffrent en année et
dont les prix sont fixes et qui sont
difficiles à renégocier malgré la hausse
des matières premières
donc il ya quand même des facteurs de
risque dans l'économique que le medef ne
sous estime pas bien sûr il ya le
souhait partagé que notre économie
reparte le plus vite possible donc c'est
peut-être pour ça vous avez cette
perception
si je complète maintenant les propos
tenus par des indiens des finances
publiques et le diagonal à la banque de
france
la tonalité va être globalement un peu
plus ambivalente je dirais et c'est bien
normal chacun dans son rôle l'état
défend son action les utilisateurs ont
une approche un petit peu plus balancée
je voudrais revenir un peu en amont sur
les mesures de compensation qui ont été
prises pendant la crise pour m'associer
à ce que vous avez dix ans au poly
ménages de présent qu'on on salue
l'effort remarquable qui a été déployée
par les administrations en particulier
celle de bercy et en particulier la
dgesip pour accompagner les entreprises
dans toutes les mesures de compensation
qui ont été prises je les appelle
mesures de compensation et non pas aide
ni soutien puisque on sait tous que
l'économie française se portaient très
bien fait
19 début 2020 et que ça n'est qu'à cause
de décisions par ailleurs légitime dans
le domaine sanitaire qu'on a connu ce
retournement de conjoncture
et par conséquent il était bien normal
que la puissance publique viennent
compenser les effets des décisions
qu'elle avait été par ailleurs obligé de
prendre
d'ailleurs on voit les résultats de
cette action remarquable puisque le
nombre de défaillances a chuté en 2020
et que la montée du chômage a été au
fond d'un tiers de celle qu'elle a été
dans la crise de 2008 2009
on a seulement seulement entre
guillemets perdu un peu plus de 300000
emplois contre 1 million dans la
précédente crise donc on voit que le
dispositif a été efficace deuxièmement
au medef on est tout à fait favorable à
la stratégie de réduction progressive
des mesures de compensation parce que
mon président a aussi dit à plusieurs
reprises il faut que le quoi qu'il en
coûte trouve abandonné sa solution au
sens chimique du terme et finissent par
laisser la place à l'économie normal si
j'ose dire
donc on a été consulté en son temps par
le ministre sur les mesures de
dégressivité du fonds de solidarité sur
le fait de restreindre aussi l'activité
partielle pour encourager les
entreprises à signer davantage de ce
qu'on appelle les appels dès les accords
d'activité partielle de longue durée qui
est d'ailleurs une proposition à
l'origine du patronat qui a été mis en
place à notre initiative et tout ceci
est normal
nous nous le soutenons même si
effectivement il faut encore soutenir
des entreprises très sectoriellement qui
sont touchés mais il est normal de
d'avoir à la fois de la dégressivité et
la sélectivité dans l'accompagnement qui
qui va suivre
d'ailleurs je ne veux dit au passage que
la l'activité partielle comme vous le
savez a coûté très cher aux finances
publiques est là où tu es là coûter
aussi très cher aux finances de l'unedic
qui porte un tiers du coût de l'eau du
chômage partiel
sarah ça représentait près de 8
milliards d'euros
ça contribue donc lourdement déficit de
l'unedic
c'est pourquoi notamment nous attendons
avec impatience la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
vous savez qu'elle est un peu en balance
aujourd'hui avec des décrets du
gouvernement qui sont attaqués conseil
d'état je le dis par parenthèse mais de
notre côté nous souhaitons vraiment que
cette réforme puisse entrer en vigueur
de manière à contribuer au
rétablissement des finances de l'unedic
et c'est aussi une façon de donner des
gages de stabilité aux entrepreneurs sur
la façon dont les grands systèmes
sociaux sont gérés à moyen long terme et
c'est ça aussi qui contribue à la
confiance et à la reprise alors j'en
viens maintenant au coeur de votre
question qu'ils aient les outils
d'accompagnement de la sortie de crise
en fait je voudrais dézoomer un petit
peu parce que il ya ce qui a été annoncé
la semaine dernière à bercy et vous y
étiez monsieur le président de
dispositifs pour favoriser en quelque
sorte la détection des difficultés en
amont et elles permettent des procédures
collectives adapté assouplies et ceci
est un élément tout à fait majeur mais
mais il n'y a pas que ça dans le
dispositif donc il faut nous pas oublier
les autres éléments qui peuvent
contribuer à la sortie de crise le
premier jeu les mentionner tout à
l'heure c'est le fait de continuer à
avoir des aides sera le partant des
compensations voyage ou moi-même pris
par mois par le vocabulaire des mesures
de compensation sélective pour certains
secteurs dont la reprise sera plus lente
que d'autres monsieur la corrège l'a
bien dit tous les secteurs ne sont pas à
la même enseigne face à la sortie de
crise on pense en particulier au
tourisme ou à l'événementiel pour lequel
la reprise sera particulièrement lente
malheureusement bon donc il faut
continuer ces dispositifs sélectif
deuxièmement si on veut prévenir les
difficultés en amont avant même
d'imaginer des dispositifs de procédures
collectives améliorée il faut éviter que
les entreprises se retrouvent là et vous
avez le plfr qui va bientôt arriver
devant vous il contient un certain
nombre de mesures auxquelles nous tenons
beaucoup et qui peuvent contribuer à
leur échelle à prévenir la survenance de
difficultés je pense en particulier au
carry back déplafonné or ça paraît un
peu technique communion mais c'est très
important pour permettre à des
entreprises qui ont subi des pertes
majeures en 2020 et qui risque d'en
subir encore en 2021
de pouvoir amortir ses pertes grâce à
des bénéfices qu'elles ont engrangés
auparavant et nous avons en tête
une trentaine d'entreprises de taille
significative qui peuvent vous qui
peuvent bénéficier de ce régime si vous
l'adoptez et qui pourrait ainsi éviter
des difficultés plus graves
il ya aussi dans ce plfr le fonds de
transition
imaginé par bercy avec sans sa dotation
de 3 milliards d'euros qui nous paraît
là aussi un instrument intéressant pour
accompagner en fonds propres ou quasi
fonds propres des entreprises avant même
qu'elle n'ait elle n'est à se présenter
devant le juge du tribunal de commerce
il y à aussi en ça peut paraître plus
anecdotique mais je le met plus dans
l'ordre symbolique dans ce plfr la
mesure dite prime macron enfin les
conditions dans lesquelles les
entreprises sont invités à verser cette
prime défiscalisées nous avons proposé
aux à vos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale un amendement sur le fait d'
assouplir ce dispositif c'est à dire
tenir compte du degré d'exposition
différents des salariés oco vide et
tenir compte aussi des autres primes
qu'ils auraient pu toucher à ce titre
bon je veux pas dire que la prime ne
paie pas à aura un effet sur la santé
financière des entreprises c'est parce
que je suis en train de dire mais à
force de de donner des injonctions aux
chefs d'entreprise sur la façon dont tu
doivent rémunérer leurs salariés ont
contribuer à un climat qui n'est pas
propice à fait d'avoir confiance en
l'avenir et de de gérer sa boutique si
vous passez l'expression tel qu'on
l'entend pour l'avenir donc voilà le
plfr est à notre avis le un deuxième
élément extrêmement important dans la
stratégie de sortie de crise que en tant
que sénateur vous pouvez prendre en
compte puisqu'il va venir devant vous
pour être votées le troisième outil
c'est donc effectivement ce plan qui a
été annoncée la semaine dernière
alors un petit détour par la méthode
jérôme l'appeler à cordes place
effectivement c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent c'est plutôt une décision de
l'état
à laquelle on a attrait ensuite les
professions du chiffre du droit puisque
la durée de concertation a été
extrêmement réduite je tiens à le
souligner de même que le vote nuitamment
d'un amendement au projet de loi sur la
sortie de crise introduisant ces
nouvelles dispositions sur les postures
collective n'a pas été du tout précédé
d'une quelconque concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux bon je le déplore
comme ça au passage après tout l'urgence
fait loi et on n'est pas aussi là ce
dispositif qui a été votée mais si on
avait été consultée auparavant on aurait
suggéré quelques petits amodiations qui
auraient pu être prises en compte
alors pour reprendre le terme de
philosophie qui est utilisée jérôme oui
le du côté du medef on est plutôt
d'accord avec cette philosophie
d'ailleurs geoffroy roux de bézieux l'a
dit la semaine dernière à bercy l'idée
de détecter en amont et de permettre aux
entreprises d'avoir une approche plus
fluide de la procédure collective et
donc moins traumatisante nous paraît une
très bonne idée
et le fait de prendre les devants et
évidemment une bonne chose
présent du medef a utilisé l'expression
latine si vis pacem para bellum donc qui
veut bien dire ce qu'elle veut dire et
on est tout à fait dans ce dans ce
registre là néanmoins il a aussi
souligné la semaine dernière vous vous
en dessous si vous vous en souvenez sans
doute président deux inconvénients
le premier c'est que psychologiquement
les entreprises ont quand même encore
une difficulté à aller vers le commerce
ça reste pour les employeurs quelque
chose d extrêmement traumatisant alors
tout ce qui peut être fait à la fois en
termes de coûts sur les procédures en
termes de facilité d'accès aux
différentes professions qui accompagnent
les chefs d'entreprise et qui donc se
trouve dans ce dispositif avec les
engagements des uns et des autres des
différentes professions concernées va
dans le bon sens mais néanmoins il faut
tous conscients qu'il ya toujours ce cet
obstacle psychologique est très présent
chez les employeurs le deuxième minorant
si j'ose dire à ce ce dispositif c'est
qu'au fond on espère nous du côté du
medef il sera très peu utilisé c'est
vrai que ont peut craindre que après une
très forte baisse des procédures
collectives en 2020 il ya une sorte de
reprise mais en fait nous on ne croit
pas trop pas tellement à ce mur des
faillites qui est qui est annoncé par
certains on pense au contraire que
certes la structure financière des
entreprises a été profondément
bouleversé la le représentant la banque
de france vient de le dire mais en même
temps nous ne pensons pas que les pge et
étaient distribuées de façon
inconsidérée
nous ne pensons pas qu'ils aient
bénéficié des entreprises zombies qui du
coup se retrouvent dans l'incapacité de
les rembourser
parce qu'il ya eu quand même ce filtre
fait par les banques et que les pg ont
été accordés à des entreprises qui
étaient quand même
normalement en mesure de le rembourser
donc on verra ce que donne dans le temps
le taux de sinistralité du pge c'est une
grande inconnue bien entendu mais nous
nous espérons nous ne pensons pas faim
les deux
les éléments se combinent qu'il n'y aura
pas donc de recours massif à cette
procédure même s'il valait mieux la
mettre en place que pas donc le dernier
élément que je voudrais mentionner comme
élément de contexte important pour la
sortie de crise c'est la confiance et ça
je dirais qu'il ya deux choses que je
voudrais dire qu'ils peuvent contribuer
à la confiance des chefs d'entreprise et
au fait qu'ils s'engagent résolument
dans le retour de la croissance aidant
dans une activité je dirais sans frein
c'est d'une part que le gouvernement
confirme qu'il n'y aura pas de hausse
d'impôt nous savons qu'un des enjeux de
la reprise c'est la désépargne des
français après qu'ils aient constitué
une et pas une massive pendant la crise
l' ocde a calculé que si seulement 20%
le fcv pardon l'eau et c'est calculé que
si seulement 20% de la sueur épargne les
fameuses 150 milliards d'euros mis de
côté par nos concitoyens été réinjectés
dans la consommation
on pourrait gagner à un point et demi de
croissance en 2021 2022
or pour que nos concitoyens décide de
désépargne et ce qu'ils ont mis de côté
dans leur bas de laine
il faut qu'il n'est pas dépendant de
précaution en prêt en prévision d'un
futur impôt donc le fait de maintenir
une stratégie fiscale visible clair
qu'il n'y aura pas de hausse d'impôts ça
nous paraît essentiel pour que cette
sortie de crise se passe convenablement
l'autre élément qui était mentionné ce
matin dans la même interview que je cite
tout à l'heure par le président du medef
c'est la question des retraites pardon
elle peut nous sembler ne rien avoir à
faire dans un débat sur la sortie de
crise mais je pense que si si
nous voulons rassurer les français
l'entente consommateurs et les
entrepreneurs en tant que donneur
d'ordres pour améliorer l'activité en
sortie de crise il faut pas que les
épées de damoclès sur des risques de
deux nouveaux débats sociaux ou le et
nous nous pensons certes qu'il faut une
réforme des retraites ça on le dit très
clairement depuis longtemps mais que ça
doit être une réforme ample suffisante
et qui dispose de la pleine légitimité
démocratique pour être fait au bon
moment et donc nous ne souhaitons pas
que il y adeux perturbations entre
maintenant et le printemps 2022 avec une
nouvelle question de ce type dans le
paysage jeux présents merci monsieur le
directeur
le propos était clair et simplement vous
avait bien évoqué c'était l'article sur
le mur des faillites que j'évoquais et
qui mène son cadet effectivement un
débat alors bur des faillites
d'expression qui qui n'est pas très
heureuse mais en tout cas la taille la
maille de ce qui est devant nous et
éventuellement nous ne le souhaitons pas
évidemment bien je vous propose de
passer maintenant la parole monsieur
william now qui est donc président du
centre d'information sur la prévention
des difficultés des entreprises et fait
donc lui demander de s'exprimer en
diminue si le veut bien
le medef a légèrement dépassé je pas
vous demander de compenser rassurez-vous
joffre avec eux plaisir mais deux
minutes ou représentants du medef donc
quelques mots liminaire peut-être pour
présenter les ces ip qui sont évidemment
est connu que les institutions qui m'ont
précédé
j'ai créé le premier c'est ip ya 25 ans
j'avais pas prévu la crise de la
pandémie
enfin déjà à l'époque les entrepreneurs
avaient du mal à aller au tribunal de
commerce c'est ça fondamentalement la
raison pour laquelle le ces ip a été
créé et je préside maintenant depuis
huit ans le sait y penas ionale qui
regroupe 1 qui chapote on va dire
les 60 à 65 c ip territoriaux j'ai aussi
été avec rené ricol en septembre octobre
2008 à la création des médiations
national du crédit j'étais à ses côtés
pour cette création pendant trois quatre
ans d'ailleurs je suis toujours en type
médiateur national délégué sur le papier
mais c'est vrai je n'exerce plus d'abord
un tout petit commentaire si je peux me
permettre sur les interventions
précédentes les mesures qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement au nom de la
vie ont été remarquables non pas
seulement en masse 1 les chiffres se
compte en milliards en 2 milliards mais
aussi dans la dentelle qui a été
construit pour par territoire par
catégorie par les fonds propres le pg ou
la trésorerie etc
donc ça c'est un commentaire général
pour une fois corps en hommage à
l'action du gouvernement de façon peu ou
prou unanimes il faut souligner le
deuxième point sur les pg e justement il
me semble est peut-être est-ce déjà un
travail en cours
il me semble qu'il serait pertinent de
réfléchir à comment ça a été dit je
crois que peur monsieur le directeur
d'un manque de france comment faire que
les entreprises qui concerne la
trésorerie du pge qui n'en n'ont pas
besoin mais par sécurité on profite
entre guillemets qui ça leur coûte un
peu de sou comme une assurance et une
enfant rien donc je me dis est ce que la
dg fip ou l'autorité publique ne
pourrait pas réfléchir le medac
d'ailleurs pourrait aussi bien comment
faire que ces entreprises investissent à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise pour acheter
du matériel renouvelé et modernisé et
c'est le numérique
je ne sais quoi et
éventuellement racheter d'autres
entreprises ou investir brassage et une
petite parenthèse comme ça en passant ça
me paraît très intéressant parce que ce
serait quand même dommage que dans
quatre cinq ans on se dise brobo ya
plein de sous ça y est c'est remboursé
donc on est content servant ceux enfin
c'est de l'argent qui aura entre
guillemets servi à rien si ce n'est
rassuré les gens ce qui est déjà
possible
alors maintenant gens bien si vous
permettez au cp les cp centre
d'information et prévention
c'est en gros alors ça regroupe toutes
les professions concernées toutes les
institutions pardon qui sont concernés
par l'accompagnement des entreprises
dont les experts comptables les avocats
les hadjis angie les les greffiers enfin
voilà toutes ces professions sont
membres du conseil d'administration du
sehy penas yonhap que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger
ça c'est un premier point dont on a par
ce réseau à étoile évidemment on diffuse
l'information et au ce on se concerte ça
c'est première chose qu'elle est le
schéma quel est le modèle du pib un chef
d'entreprise à une difficulté n'importe
laquelle n'importe quel bobo n'importe
qu'elle craint de maladie n'importe quoi
on le reçoit on le reçoit un
expert-comptable bénévoles un avocat
bénévole un ancien juge consulaire qui
n'est pas en fonction bénévole ces trois
personnes sont totalement indépendantes
n'ont pas le droit en particulier les
experts comptables avocats de garder le
chef d'entreprise reçu comme clients
c'est pas une opération commerciale ça
va être totalement désintéressé et j'ai
vraiment jamais eu d'incident il y en a
eu il ya deux ans ça s'est résolu très
vite et puis
le chef d'entreprise vient les mains
dans les poches ou accompagné de son
avocat son expert comptable avec un
bilan semble enfin il vient tel qu'il
est et la grâce au dialogue
il est éclairé sur comment s'y prendre
et c est bien sûr ça a été rappelée y
compris dans le l'événement enfin la
charte du 1er juin à laquelle les ip
d'ailleurs sont si les terres il
il a des idées sur les issues possibles
tribunal de commerce avec le discours
convaincu le tribunal de commerce est
pas je comprends votre expression la
faillite
c'est pas forcément toujours la
liquidation ça peut être un certain
nombre de solutions sauvegarde d'un doc
etc qui permettent à l'entrepreneur de
sauver ce qui peut sauver compris
totalement son entreprise mais il ya
aussi le leur voix la suggestion dallas
à la médiation du crédit etc
nous travaillons je le disais tout à
l'heure et toutes nous avons 60 plus de
66 p sur territoire qui reçoit
physiquement les gens ça reprend
maintenant après le coc vide
nous le faisons au téléphone nous avons
été extrêmement étonné en début d'année
j'avoue que j'avais beau lippi disent
aimer mais 500 bénévoles et finalement
on s'est aperçu
ça a été dit que le nom de faillite et
difficultés étaient extrêmement faibles
et on ne sait pas on va essayer d'éviter
ce qu'on appelle le mur des faillites
c'est à dire une arrivée en masse de
défaillant je pense que les dispositifs
la mobilisation du 1er juin qui ainsi
toutes les parties prenantes y compris
près humblement la nôtre paix y compris
vers les grandes institutions qui sont
conservés par l'entreprise je crois que
c'est une très bonne chose parce qu'on
communique bon travail de btf à classer
pme avec lui du p on travaille avec la
confédération des commerces et 350 mille
commerçants sont représentés nos clients
entre guillemets ce sont des petites
entreprises les peut-être moins de 750
milles et tout petit lit n'ont pas
forcément toujours des experts
comptables et tout je suis par ailleurs
président du comité prévention de
l'ordre des experts comptables
j'étais présent de l'ordre à dsk
coupable bien longtemps et à ce titre
avec les autres services de l'ordre
on a mis en place un autodiagnostic je
le signale parce que les gens qui nous
écoutent pourraient être intéressés une
entreprise qui n'a pas d'expert
comptable peut s'adresser à l'ordre
national des experts comptables pour
bénéficier d'un autodiagnostic y compris
avec l'accompagnement un
expert-comptable bénévoles donc c'est
vraiment tout à fait inédit qu'une
institution représentative le fin j'ai
des contacts aussi avec le barreau de
paris etc
voilà donc jeu j'en reste là mais il
avance ya les questions je serais
heureux dit répond ainsi même si
monsieur le pen appelle ainsi monsieur
le merci monsieur le président merci à
vous tous pour ouvrir ce débat avec des
éléments tout à fait tout à fait
important pour ma part je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs je crois
la semaine dernière j'ai deux
interrogations alors la première c'est
la vision d'être brut dette nette sur
lequel est un élément macro économique
réelle mais qui ne dit rien mais vous
l'avez repréciser qui ne dit rien en
réalité de la répartition
la question qui est majeur on peut avoir
des entreprises qui ont des pg très
important qui disent qu'ils disent pas
et que n'auront pas besoin d'inciter ce
cas et on en connaît et qui d'ailleurs
les rembourserons quelquefois assez
rapidement et j'en connais également
dans ma région même été plus petit qui
vont le rembourser immédiatement on a le
cas inverse c'est à dire des gens qui
ont bénéficié de pge et qui des zones
déjà consommé intégralement
on a donc des liens dette trésorerie qui
sont très disparates
donc vous l'avez site et vous avez dit
13% des entreprises ils sont dans une
cas donc très haut prendre
l'augmentation de la dette grande de
baisse de la trésorerie et donc c'est la
première cible mais j'en vois d'autres
et notamment je vois je les félicite et
l'année dernier les questions qui sont
liées à la reprise aidant la reprise
tout en cours on revient à l'état de
normal de l'entreprise c'est à dire que
les salaires doivent être payés les
chats doivent être payés etc
et il y a des difficultés sur la
facturation c'est à dire sur les
rentrées et pourquoi il ya des
difficultés sur les rentrées parce que
ça tombe d'entreprise n'arrive pas à
produire définitivement leurs produits
parce que on est dans un système où il
ya des blocages sur la filière et en
particulier on voit là d'ailleurs toute
la difficulté sur la remise en route
d'un coup du nom d'une figure un total
et non pas dans le cadre
j'allais dire d'une reprise des
fournisseurs des matières premières etc
puis petit à petit de la production
derrière
or ce système est embouteillée de
manière très forte aujourd'hui dans
certains domaines où les producteurs
initiaux si je puis dire qui sont les
plus jeunes à mots ne sont pas capables
de fournir ceux qui sont le plus en aval
ce qui veut dire qu'on a des besoins de
fonds de roulement plus important et
donc des besoins de trésorerie qui
peuvent augmenter de manière très forte
donc ça c'est des sujets me semble-t-il
très concret et moi qui prends l'avion
toutes les semaines pour venir ici dans
chaque avion
je peux vous le dire j'ai toujours deux
chefs d'entreprise pour venir me dire
tout de suite
est ce que vous allez faire quelque
chose sur ce sujet là donc voilà on le
ressent très fortement ça veut pas dire
qu'en termes de chiffre d'affaires ou
terme
global et magro ce soit très visible
mais en tout cas c'est une difficulté je
voudrais la cité monsieur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président merci messieurs pour lui
exposer pour moi qui ai la chance de
pouvoir prendre le tgv sur le président
dont je rappelle au passage est géré à
longueuil c'est bien non mais parce que
aujourd'hui on nous explique que c'est
plus vertueuses qui n'est pas faux mais
c est aussi s'agissant du tgv est le
premier tgv en france qui avaient été
financés avec la participation des
collectivités
voilà je fermais la page
je voulais faire une observation et
trois questions d'abord je m'inscrire
dans les propos du président claude
raynal sur l'état d'esprit qui anime
notre assemblée le sénat sur le souhait
de voir la france sortir enfin traiter
la condition là la crise sanitaire dans
les meilleures conditions et réussir au
mieux la sortie de crise parce que et je
veux donner un chiffre un seul mais qui
doit être intégré à ce que vous avez
donné que j'ai repris d'ailleurs dans le
rapport que j'ai présentée récemment sur
la manière dont tour pourrait sortir de
la crise ont regardé des dispositifs pge
c'est que en france nos entreprises ont
conservé 22 % de la perte de revenus
enregistrés à leur charge
c'est 0% en allemagne et ce en moyenne
européenne 7%
c est aussi pour avoir un constat
objectif lucide partagés sur les
conditions dans lesquelles l'entreprise
finalement en france se trouve
aujourd'hui sur d'ailleurs globalement
le diagnostic
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire la semaine
dernière
aux mines oud ou plus au ministre plutôt
il y en avait 2 bruno le maire est eric
dupond moretti sur globalement le
diagnostic un certain nombre de mesures
on se retrouve et notamment sur la
sortie de crise au travers du triptyque
identifié orienté traité alors pour
l'identification
le gouvernement choisit entre autres
choses de s'appuyer sur le dispositif
dit signaux faibles
à propos duquel lors des auditions que
j'avais conduite
la banque de france s'était montré
plutôt réservé donc qu'en est il
vraiment quel et éventuellement le point
de vue des entreprises et peut-être de
quelle manière
ça a été évoqué je vais revenir aussi
mobilisé les bons leviers suffisamment
tôt pour réduire le maximum les
difficultés et les risques
deuxième sujet qui est en lien le
gouvernement propose de s'appuyer sur
deco défi élargi ce que j'avais appelé
les les
les comités finalement avec plusieurs
acteurs de sortie de crise donc les ce
que j'avais appeler l'hélico fille stock
moi j'ai besoin quand même de savoir de
connaître deux choses 1
l'association et le fonctionnement
l'association ce qu'on avait proposé ce
qui se dit ce qui a été dit également ce
matin parce que que des fils était
uniquement l'état entre guillemets et
ces opérateurs qui ceux qui parlaient et
qui décide et à l'endroit des
entreprises
aujourd'hui ce qui est souhaité c'est
que l'ensemble des acteurs qu'ils soient
du monde de la banque
effectivement les professions du droit
et du chiffre peut-être des acteurs
publics soit autour de la table parce
qu'il ya des enjeux économiques et de
développement mais a aussi des enjeux
d'emplois dans les territoires et tout
doit être entendue puisque il peut y
avoir des dispositifs d'accompagnement
qui en raison de circonstances dans le
territoire amen ou amèneront peut-être
des collectivités à devoir prendre aux
dispositifs d'accompagnement ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut pas non plus que ce soit
dans l'organisme décision une enceinte
dans laquelle il y aurait 30 ou 40
personnes qui désireraient on voit bien
que ça ne peut pas être fonctionnel il
faut à la fois les acteurs soient tous
bien représentée avec la décision puisse
être prise avec le plus d'objectivité de
professionnalisme et d'efficacité
donc quel est votre point de vue puis
enfin vous avez parlé on n'a pas aidé un
soutien qui doit devenir plus ciblées je
partage évidemment et vous ne l'avez pas
évoqué mais enfin vous l'avez évoqué ici
pour le carry back que le que notre
assemblée depuis l'été dernier soutien à
qui le gouvernement avait à chaque fois
opposé un refus à ces fermes au motif
que c'est un dispositif qui est serait
coûteux je suis pas sûr qu'il soit aussi
coûteux que ceux là en tous les cas je
vois que le gouvernement a changé de
pied de fusil d'épaulé qu'il a revu sa
copie
c'est bien vous nous expliquer sur le
directeur général que ça concernerait
une trentaine d'entreprises ou pourrait
peut-être nous en dire plus mais on a
également proposé une deuxième piste et
que je ne vois pas pour l'instant
reprises par le gouvernement qui est la
déduction fiscale pour le capital à
risque pour finalement
neutraliser le biais en faveur de
l'endettement et encourager le
financement sur fonds propres donc
comment recevez-vous aujourd'hui
monsieur directeur général cette
proposition pourquoi c'est pas dans les
mesures retenues et le directeur général
qui compense les entreprises quel est le
regard qu'elle porte sur ce dispositif
merci merci monsieur rapporteur général
je fais un accord avec le rapporteur
général proposé à nos collègues tout de
suite d'intervenir de manière à ce que
nous inviter puisse répondre à
l'ensemble des questions je signale que
monsieur naoum sera le premier à
répondre parce que nous serons dans
l'ordre inverse si je puis dire et nous
finirons par monsieur fournaise qui aura
comme lourde tâche de vérifier que j'ai
eu des réponses à toutes les questions
et celles qui n'ont pas trouvé encore de
réponse de bien vouloir répondre merci
je vous prépare à cet exercice
et je rappelle à mes collègues qu'ils
veuillent bien s'inscrire le plus
rapidement possible de manière à ce
qu'on gère bien le temps en sachant que
deux minutes toujours un maximum vous le
savez alors roger karoutchi pour deux
minutes
[Musique]
monsieur le président sur la porte en
général messieurs je suis toujours
admiratif devant la bonne humeur
générale et le embrassons-nous colline
on a l'impression que il s'est quasi
rien passer et que tout le monde dit on
sort de la crise
c'est terminé et on s'en sort bien on se
sent même très bien alors je ne doute
pas que naturellement
j'étais favorable on les a votés
d'ailleurs à tous les pfr apportant des
aides aux entreprises et aux mais il ya
un bilan à la fin le bilan c'est que
l'état est beaucoup plus endettés c'est
que les collectivités locales sont
exsangues et c'est que les entreprises
malgré tout on l'a dit tout à l'heure
sont plus endettées qu'elle ne l'était
il ya deux ans
alors est-ce que bien sûr il y avait
elle est à la reprise la messe que quand
même au delà de 2021 avec l'espèce de
sourire de tous deux d'espérer sortir de
la pandémie en espérant bien qu'il ait
pas de quatrième vague
auquel cas tous nos calculs soient à
nouveau faux mais est ce que ça ne veut
pas dire quand même que sur 2022 2023
2024 vous allez avoir un état qui par
définition plus endettés il ya eu des
déficits lourd en 2020 21 va bien sûr de
voir un moment considérablement réduire
la voilure
donc ces investissements est ce que les
collectivités locales elles mêmes
exemples vont pas être dans la même
situation
et est-ce qu'en réalité on va pas avoir
une embellie l'a peut-être au deuxième
semestre 2021
peut-être début 2000 22 mai avec le
contre-coup dans les années qui viennent
parce que forcément c'est un tous les
acteurs privés les acteurs publics
tout le monde contribue à l'économie si
les acteurs publics sont extrêmement
d'été et les taux d'intérêt remontent et
si les acteurs privés certes sont en
convalescence mais quand même plus
endettés qu'ils ne l'étaient
est ce que au delà de la bonne humeur
générale pour la reprise 2021 est-ce
qu'il ya pas un fort risque 2022 2023
merci rouge et sylvie vermeillet en
ligne sylvie bonjour
le président bonjour à toutes et tous
alors j'ai bien pris connaissance du
plan d'action sur l'accompagnement des
entreprises en sortie de crise et
j'aurai deux interrogations sur deux
articles différents
première interrogation sur l'article 13
l'état permet la possibilité de prêts
participatifs exceptionnelle pour les
entreprises et ce à pouvoir couvrir les
besoins en investissements et en fonds
de roulement je m'étonne
une fois de plus qu'on ne prévoit pas la
question du financement du besoin en
fonds de roulement en sortie de crise
ça rejoint un peu l'exposé du président
reynal tout à l'heure les entreprises
elles sont en redémarrage
elles doivent reconstituer leurs stocks
avec des stocks
dont coût des matières premières va être
plus élevé et c'est donc des stocks qui
sont onéreux elles doivent refinancer le
décalage d'encaissement des classements
entre les filles et les fournisseurs et
les clients et donc je vois pas de
dispositif pour accompagner le besoin en
fonds de roulement des entreprises
je vois plus du financement de haut de
bilan avec cette possibilité de financer
le fond de roulement mais pas le besoin
en fonds de roulement et ça me semble
important ou alors est-ce que vous
considérez que les excédents de
trésorerie constitué par les pge sont là
justement pour financer le besoin en
fonds de roulement
mais à mon avis ça mérite d'avoir une
attention sur ce redémarrage en sortie
de crise qui va nécessiter de la
trésorerie pour les entreprises
deuxième point sur l'article 15 vous
avez la possibilité de mettre en place
des plans d'apurement des dettes
fiscales et sociales pour allonger ses
dettes qui sont déjà consentis est ce
que ça veut dire qu'à ce stade il n'y a
aucun abandon de créance qui est prévu
merci merci sylvie michel canevet depuis
stephen total
merci à monsieur le président merci à
nos intervenants pour leur précision
dans les échos ce matin le président du
medef disait que l'europe par sa
capacité à nous unir à tous comptes
faits a été plutôt efficace oui je pense
que les actions qui ont été maintenus en
conduit à permettre à beaucoup
d'entreprises de pouvoir surmonter la
crise et les chiffres qui ont été donnés
tout à l'heure sont intéressants à cet
égard je voulais tout d'abord savoir
quel au niveau des pe
si on a une idée du taux de mobilisation
des péchés c'est à dire quelle est la
part des entreprises qui finalement
souscrit des pg ou dvd à la pub en 140
milliards mais qui ne les ont pas
utilisé c'est déjà un élément qui
permettra de d'apprécier réellement la
situation
je voulais aussi savoir quelles étaient
des secteurs qui étaient les plus à
risque dans les secteurs qui ont été
identifiées on peut penser que
l'événementiel par exemple est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres secteurs qui globalement
sont identifiés très à risque
ensuite on s'aperçoit là à l'examen des
comptes de l'état que la peau sur les
sociétés les recettes d'impôt sur les
sociétés sont en hausse par rapport à ce
qui était prévu + 3 milliards ou certes
moins 9 milliards par rapport à ce qu'on
est prévue au projet de loi de finances
initiale mais c'est quand même un peu
mieux qu est ce qui était prévu et puis
les recettes de tva de la même façon
même si elles sont en baisse de 11
milliards par rapport aux prévisions
initiales elles sont finalement
supérieur de 2 milliards à ce qui était
prévu dans les plf r est ce que c'est un
signe que l'on peut considérer comme
étant positif sur une amélioration de la
situation des entreprises en 2020 malgré
la crise que l'on a connu puis dernière
question c'est la question d'aider des
risques liés à la situation financière
est ce que vous pensez que
à 100 de l'entreprise fond fragile et
fragilisé au point de peut-être de
risquer d'être racheté par des
entreprises extérieures
et est ce que c'est cette crise n'est
finalement pas un moyen de pouvoir aussi
engager des actions de relocalisation
d'activités est ce que vous avez bon
espoir que ceux ci puissent permettre
devons notamment des difficultés
d'approvisionner notre pays de
relocaliser donc des activités et donc
des emplois dans notre pays merci michel
stéphane sautarel puis bernard delcros
merci monsieur le président merci notre
rapporteur général et et aux différents
intervenants fait je vais me limiter à
trois questions sur les outils dont
certains ont déjà été évoquées notamment
par le rapporteur général
le premier c'est effectivement vous
interrogé plus avant sur le carry back
non seulement sur la nécessité de sa
mise à neuf comme ça a été soulignée
mais je suis surpris par le nombre
limité à priori d'entreprises
bénéficiaires possiblement vous avez
évoqué or c'est un système qui pourrait
permettre de répondre effectivement plus
largement à des besoins d'entreprises en
lissant et en ayant effectivement a
posteriori cette cette possibilité qui
me semble répondre à des besoins
d'entreprises y compris de plus petite
taille en tout cas c'est un certain
nombre de messages qui me sont remontés
un deuxième question sur eux
effectivement comme ma collègue sur les
prêts participatifs pour les tpe
je m'interrogeais pour savoir comme cela
avait pu être évoqué si sur certains
secteurs en grande difficulté sur
certains types de tpe
il ne fallait pas aller plus loin
certains collègues a évoqué les remises
de dettes sociales et là je m'interroge
sur la transformation de certains pge en
subventions pour des tpe dans des
conditions qui resterait bien sûr un à
préciser mais est ce que cette piste est
totalement écartée ou est ce qu'elle
peut être envisagée
et enfin une troisième troisième
question qui concerne aussi les fonds
propres des entreprises
aujourd'hui les mesures semblent
relativement limité sur les fonds
propres des entreprises les prêts
participatifs sont des quasi fonds
propres ils peuvent répondre à un
certain nombre de besoins
mais les enveloppes qui sont mises à
disposition notamment le fonds de
transition semble assez limité et ma
question porte donc sur un outil nouveau
qui permettrait justement pour répondre
à la confiance d'une garantie de l'état
qui pourrait être accordée aux
épargnants pour permettre de venir
renforcer les fonds propres des
entreprises par un dispositif qui
pourrait être incitatif est soutenu par
l'état
je vous remercie oui merci monsieur le
président merci à tous les intervenants
pour les informations extrêmement
précises qu'ils nous ont apportés moi
j'ai deux questions la première porte
sur les pg e des prêts garantis par
l'état ont constitué un lieu important
de soutien à l'économie dans le pays
attend une idée avez vous pouvez vous
évaluer la part de ses péchés que vous
avez évoqué thaler 339 milliards au
total la part qui au final ne pourra pas
être remboursée par les entreprises dans
la mesure où vous ces prêts sont
garantis par par l'état deuxième
question vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
la la hausse très importante du coût des
matières premières qui place un certain
nombre d'entreprises du bâtiment en
difficulté selon vous est-ce que cette
hausse très importante et rapide du coût
des matières premières et durable ou ou
plutôt passagère je vous remercie
c'est bernard gérard longuet pu tirer
cozic
oui merci monsieur le président merci
chers rapporteur général je remercie nos
invités de leur communication j'ai une
seule question et une observation la
question c'est la répartition des pertes
en ce qui concerne les pge entre l'état
et les banques et les modalités que vous
envisagez pour gérer cette répartition
des pertes qui peuvent aller soit 21 des
tribunaux de commerce ou soit faire
l'objet imagine déménagement de la part
de vos comités l'observation je rejoins
la crainte de roger karoutchi et jeu-là
précise la sortie du du fossile et du
thermique n'est pas une affaire facile
je pense que l'industrie aéronautique
est quand même confronté alors qu'elle
est décisive dans notre pays à une
situation de d'interrogation l'énergie
électrique et le nucléaire la sortie du
fossile le gaz charbon n'est pas achevé
et à une dimension sociale et nous
découvrons l'automobile thermique ne
s'est pas une affaire facile non plus et
nous découvrons par ailleurs qu'il y à
des goulots technique alors a été évoqué
le bâtiment c'est le problème des
matériaux de la filière des matériaux et
apparaît également le goulot en matière
d'emploi s'étaient également évoqué dans
nos ce matin matière d'emploi dans des
secteurs dont on pouvait penser qu'il
redémarrerait facilement l'hôtellerie la
restauration l'événementiel mais qui
sont manifestement confrontés à des
problèmes de manoeuvre disponibles
je voulais savoir si vous aimez partager
cette inquiétude sur les filières
merci gérard thiery cozic puis christian
bilhac merci monsieur le président un
constat
la stratégie du quoi qu'il en coûte à
porter ses fruits
globalement l'économie française a quand
même enregistré de récession record qui
ait jamais observé depuis depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale mais dans le
même temps le nombre de faillites bas
également des records et à la baisse
c'est vrai que nous n'aurons jamais
connu aussi peu de défaillances
d'entreprises depuis 30 ans notamment
dans les pme
néanmoins le temps de la sortie
progressive des aides est aujourd'hui
arrivée et est ce qu'à un moment donné
il faudra pas que la crise s'exprime
les mesures de soutien qui ont fourni la
liquidité aux entreprises sous forme de
prêt notamment le pg aux deux reports de
charges sociales et fiscales ne font que
renvoyer la difficulté à plus tard c'est
vrai que ces aides ont artificiellement
maintenir un certain nombre
d'entreprises en vie l'endettement brut
des entreprises non financières
aujourd'hui a augmenté de 170 milliards
entre février et septembre ce qui permet
témoin d'expression constitue quand même
une singularité française
c'est dans cet endettement il cache
aussi d'autres dettes notamment du fait
des reports des impôts des impôts et des
cotisations donc une question dans cette
perspective ne faut ne faut-il pas dès
maintenant réfléchir à des critères
opérationnels d'annulation sélective de
dettes pour notamment pour éviter les
effets d'aubaine et lorsque cela sera
possible
est ce qu'une approche au cas par cas
pourraient être nécessaires pour mettre
à contribution les banques les
entreprises et pas seulement l'argent
public les dernières dernière question
pour terminer dans cette configuration
et pour employer une métaphore sanitaire
je crois qu'il est plutôt de du goût du
jour quelles mesures concrètes vous
semble aujourd'hui judicieuse pour
juguler l'hémorragie qui se profile
lorsque les perfusions seront retirés
si thierry christian bilhac je marie
miso
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues messieurs merci pour votre
éclairage
je vais pour ma part vous faire part de
l'échelle informelle que j'ai eues la
semaine dernière avec une poignée de
chefs d'entreprises de très petites
entreprises alors que vous faire des
réflexions mais des réflexions qui sont
aussi des questions quelque part
premières réflexions l'annulation des
pêcheurs qui reste une espérance une
croyance fantasmes je sais pas mais
certains ont dit mais finalement j'ai
prêché sont garanties par l'état
peut-être qu'on n'aura pas les
rembourser voilà donc ça et je crois
qu'il faut le clarification de là dessus
même si elle a déjà eu lieu il demeure
cette espérance où ce faux espoir de ne
pas avoir remboursé ses prêts donc là
moi je ne pense à l'accompagnement a été
saluée quand même par la plupart les
chefs d'entreprise que tu là et la
deuxième question alors c'était l'effet
de seuil qui était je sais pas s'il
était espéré ou redouté mais qui a un
effet de seuil sur la sortie de crise où
je dirais joue pas 50% qu'une entreprise
qui ont fait réaliser que 49,5 pour ça
le chiffre d'affaires l'année précédente
bénéficient des de sortie de crise et
que ding reprise que réalisé 50,3 % se
verrait cru dispositif
voilà donc ce s'était fait des chèques
et quand même redouter un peu comme le
fameux 30 pour tard et un moment chez
les deux réflexions quelques témoignages
qu'ils ne remplacent pas la connaissance
de monsieur beau au niveau du medef il
s'agit de dauphin contraintes formelles
avec un petit panel mais je tenais à
vous faire part le fait de faire
réflexion de les recueillir
l'acier christian jean marie mise on
peut terminer
merci monsieur le président merci aussi
à nouveaux intervenants pour la qualité
de leurs interventions je partage la
volonté du gouvernement de favoriser à
l'atterrissage en douceur par paliers de
notre économie est d'accompagner celles
des entreprises qui sont encore
fortement touchés pour apporter cet
accord pas du moins plus loin mais ce
plan de d'accompagnement précisément ne
sera une réussite que s'il est connu par
tous que s'il chacun se l'approprient
notamment les petites entreprises
ma question est simple dès lors c'est ce
que vous avez imaginé un plan de
communication pertinent pour que chacun
de ceux qui sont concernés puissent
profiter de l'accompagnement mis en
place à la faveur de la sortie de crise
merci jean marie je me tourne donc vers
nos invités pour les questions qu'ils
souhaitent traiter bien entendu il n'y a
pas d'obligation de traiter l'ensemble
des questions
en tout cas pour chacun d'entre vous
sinon nous serions un petit peu long et
or dd je vous rappelle que nous
essaierons de terminer cette audition
des rondeurs
donc je vous suggère dans les cinq
minutes les thèmes qui vous ont paru les
plus proches de vos préoccupations
sinon oui j'ai envie de répondre à
toutes les questions d'effectivement on
va sectorisé si je veux dire d'abord une
première un premier pas très rapide
l'essai ip apportent aussi leur soutien
psychologique puisque nous avons un
accord avec apesa que tout le monde
connaît ou lorsque nos bénévoles
constatent une défaillance psychologique
à risque suicidaire d'un chef
d'entreprise reçues il lui propose avec
délicatesse
on les a formés pour ça à
l'accompagnement psychologique est pris
en charge par le cep n'a siona je ferme
cette parenthèse l'autre point peut-être
gelé pas souligner tout à l'heure c'est
un beau la vie
le problème principal en vain il ya la
dette de la france à ces c'est entre
guillemets en main mais aussi le chômage
et la détresse des salariés
j'ai relevé d'ailleurs un grand patron
français avait créé un fonds pour ses
salariés ce qui était dans une situation
de détresse
il me semble que c'est quelque chose
auquel les employeurs
doivent effectivement porter une certain
intentions pourrait répondre peut-être
il ya beaucoup de sujets qui peut
m'intéresser sur bfr landais plan le
gouverneur la banque de france avait
donné premiers joints des statistiques
sur la dette et la trésorerie et l'écart
était effectivement d'une dizaine de
milliards si je me trompe pas par contre
monsieur le sénateur karoutchi voudrais
faire une observation
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire
qu'il qu'il ya un petit vent d'optimisme
par ci par là je crois qu'il faut s'en
féliciter s'en réjouir
moi je me souviens très bien que en
février-mars semaine dernière j'ai
mobilisé comme si on allait à la guerre
mais mes collègues et des 500 bénévoles
je leur ai dit méfiez-vous ça va être
quelque chose
est ce que vous êtes sûr de pouvoir être
là etc et à mesure que le temps passait
la déclaration très forte du président
la république sur le entend quoi qu'il
en coûte dont vous en souvenez les
mesures prises au fur et à mesure et le
constat qu' il n'y avait pas de faillite
autant joints de liquidation de
difficultés autant qu'on le craignait et
donc c'est le seul sénateur
l'écart entre la crainte qu'on avait
d'arriver à une catastrophe économique
majeur avec beaucoup beaucoup de dépôts
de bilan et la réalité qui est certes
pas rose mais qui est quand même
infiniment moins inquiétante à ce jour
que celle qu'on craignait
monsieur le représentant de la banque de
france a dit j'ai des antennes par
ailleurs avec le système jedeclare.com
des experts comptables on constate que
dans des secteurs très contre intuitif
par exemple les restaurants bien sûr y
en a qui sont devant un mur de dettes
qui sont très bon vous êtes un pécule
hop allemand et sont infimes
macroéconomique mans infiniment moins
les bilans bilan ça veut dire quelque
chose sont infiniment moins dramatique
qu on aurait pu le craindre donc ça ne
veut pas dire il faut travailler
probablement salle a été dis bien tout à
l'heure par les secteurs où il ya des
vrais problèmes où il ya des risques
majeurs et ses essais en continuant ce
travail entre guillemets de dentelle de
de précision que l'on arrivera à
colmater les brèches
un tant soit peu juste un petit point
pour dire que je soutiens l'idée qui a
été suggéré tout à l'heure sur le carry
back et enfin à titre tout à fait
personnel et j'en resterai là un voeu
il ya 40 ans quelques-uns d'entre vous
ont peut-être peuvent avoir ce genre de
souvenir je regardais quasi
mensuellement les statistiques la
balance commerciale de la france et de
l'allemagne et que ces deux pays qui
m'intéressait ils étaient franchement
pas du tout au déshonneur de la france
une fois c'était une fois c'était mon
fait j'ai pas le chiffre global annuel
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on va approcher
les 160 200 milliards de de différents
jeux j'espère que cette crise permettra
à la france de réindustrialiser j'ai
beaucoup travaillé dans des entreprises
où il y avait des usines et c'est avec
beaucoup de douleur que je ressens tila
désastre réalisation de la france
l'allemagne a réussi par la qualité a
gardé son industrie je pense qu'un
effort à tous les milliards dépensés
travail un effort à faire et le deuxième
point que jouer c c'est ce qui semble
être dans le tunnel les secteurs
stratégiques faire ensemble que la
france soit indépendant avoir pendant
six mois
ah je m'exprime à titre personnel si je
peux me permettre avoir à se demander si
on va recevoir des masques de la chine
qu'on achète à dix bals les 50
aujourd'hui
je trouve ça assez dramatique je ferme
la parenthèse je fais confiance à toutes
les parties prenantes
pour que nous allions dans ce sens y
compris à vous messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur
merci monsieur le président j'ai fait
effectivement un peu de picking sur six
questions puisque jérôme fera en quelque
sorte la somme de l'ensemble des
questions si j'ai bien compris monsieur
le rapporteur général pour revenir à
votre suggestion d'une mesure en faveur
du capital risque
oui le medef il est favorable ça vous
surprendra pas il n'est pas encore né le
directeur du medef qui serait contre une
déduction fiscale dans ce set
ça nous semble d'ailleurs ressembler
beaucoup à la proposition numéro six du
rapport du de fait votre rapport pardon
je l'apprends général donc nous y sommes
favorables parce que effectivement on
constate bien que dans le financement
les intérêts de la dette sont exonérés
et donc de ce fait là ça favorise en
quelque sorte un directement les
financement par endettement au détriment
des fonds propres donc une mesure qui
peut contribuer à rééquilibrer en faveur
des fonds propres en exonérant les
intérêts même si c'est pas exactement
l'or l'or lors des nominations technique
nous paraît dans le bon sens jerem un
cran plus loin c'est que toute mesure
qui favorise la cohésion de fonds
propres est bonne est donc la principale
déductions fiscales en faveur des fonds
propres c'est la baisse du taux d s est
donc nous nous souhaitons qu
effectivement la trajectoire qui était
dessiné par le gouvernement permettant
d'arriver à 25% donc et une moyenne et
en dépit des signaux contraires envoyés
par les états unis avec le plan by donne
nous souhaitons que cette stratégie du
gouvernement soient maintenues et entre
en actions si j'ose dire deuxième
question alors plus politique le point
soulevé par monsieur le sénateur
karoutchi je répondrai un petit peu
comme william naoum on sait tous que
dans l'économie c'est du capital c'est
de la dette mais c'est aussi des hommes
et des femmes salariées employeurs
consommateurs et que donc c'est aussi
essentiellement de la psychologie
donc oui à peut-être un peu trop
d'optimisme dans l'air pour reprendre
votre expression mais cet optimisme est
nécessaire pour aller de l'avant donc
indépendamment des analyses politiques
moi j'invite tout le monde a essayé de
se tourner vers le verre à moitié plein
sans quoi effectivement nous aurons des
prédictions auto-réalisatrice sur les
difficultés économiques qui sont devant
nous si au contraire on accompagne le
mouvement
c'est ce qui créera de la croissance de
l'emploi et donc des capacités à
rembourser notre dette et à être en
meilleure situation financière que ce
soit pour les pouvoirs publics ou pour
les entreprises sur la question posée
par votre collègue madame v remis et je
crois sur le besoin en bfr s'arrogeant
que le président ce que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure on a oublié mentionné je
crois peut-être le fait que les pge sont
enfin prolongé jusqu'au 31 décembre de
cette année pour pouvoir être mis en
place par les entreprises
ça veut dire que les entreprises qui
auraient aujourd'hui des difficultés du
bfr peuvent toujours jusqu'au 31
décembre cette année se tourner vers
leurs banquiers pour mettre en place un
peu de ça reste possible il faut pas
oublier cette possibilité un autre de
vos collègues et a mentionné les
difficultés entre les prêts
participatifs et les tpe
je confirme que nous du côté du patronat
on pense que les préparatifs sont pas
l'outil le plus adapté aux tpe
alors faut-il pour autant remplacer ces
prêts participatifs par des exonérations
plus massive de charges sociales ou de
houe d'impôts ça je vais pas aller
jusque là j'ai dit ce que je pensais
tout à l'heure ce que le medef pensait
du quoi qu'il en coûte
donc je n'irai pas
jusqu'à cette proposition est ce que les
matières premières connaissent une
hausse durable sur le sénateur si je le
savais je serai traders dans une banque
d'affaires
je ne sais pas en revanche ce que nous
indique que les entreprises c'est que
elle pense qu'effectivement il ya un
problème d'ajustement entre une
économique était alors relativement à
l'arrêt pendant de longs mois
pas seulement en france bien entendu
mais dans l'ensemble des économies
développées et que donc on venait ont
fait face à un problème d'ajustement
entre l'offre et la demande
vous l'avez très bien dit les uns les
autres les différents boulet
d'étranglement et qui se font jour dans
l'économie donc nous pensons que c'est
un mouvement plutôt conjoncturelle qui
devrait trouver sa résolution
prochainement mais ce n'est pas une
certitude c'est pas une prédiction
enfin dernière question sur laquelle je
voudrais intervient sur les effets de
seuils mentionnés par monsieur sénateurs
du côté du medef
on a fait notre deuil si j'ose dire de
cette contrainte qui est mécanique si on
veut avoir des compensations d'un côté
il faut bien qu'ils aient des ce qu'ils
soient définies d'un autre donc c'est
vrai que ça a des effets de bord sur
toujours agréable pour certaines
entreprises sont à la limite mais c'est
un peu incontournable en revanche ce que
j'observe c'est que dans sa stratégie de
dégressivité du fonds solidarité
l'état a mis en place un système qui
nous paraît intelligent qui est d'avoir
à baisser très fortement le seuil pour
rentrer dans le mécanisme
puisqu'on est plus à 50% de père de jets
d'affaires mais à seulement 10% et qu'en
revanche le soutien la compensation qui
est apportée et l dégressive avec des
paliers de 40 % 30 % 20 %
ça nous paraît être en partie une
réponse à votre préoccupation est celle
qui vous ont été apportées par les chefs
d'entreprise que vous avez rencontrées
je pèse ainsi monsieur directeur
génotype passage regardera dans les
années qui viennent si c'est bien le cas
que vous souhaitiez que les la baisse
des taux d'imposition des entreprises se
traduisent par une augmentation des
fonds propres
on n'a pas tout à fait constaté dans le
passé mais je doute pas qu'à l'avenir ce
soit le cas en tout cas
jean forme le voeu disons monsieur le
directeur la banque de france merci je
faisais dans quand quand un dividende
est versée il est souvent réinvesti par
l'anc l'entrepreneur je le prends tout
je le prends dans tout ça sa globalité
aussi quand je vais reprendre
effectivement si un certain nombre de
points important complément de prison
vous parliez puis plusieurs plusieurs
d'entre vous aussi avait réaborder la
question de de l'endettement et la
vision dette brute dette nette
et puis les questions si du lien
derrière le bfr la capacité à rebondir
je voudrais insister sur ce sujet qui
est quand même un des sujets cruciaux de
la capacité du pays à rebondir après la
crise les chiffres macro 1 sur le sur
l'endettement et sur la trésorerie des
entreprises montrent que alors sur sur
la dette brute on est passé à fin 2010
9,2 fin 2010 9 à fin 2020 donc sur une
année donc l'année de la crise 2683
milliards à 1890 milliards donc on a
quand même gagné
si je puis dire 218,9 précisément
milliards d'euros de dettes de
l'entreprise en dette brute en dette
brute en trésorerie
le pan dont et c'est là que le mouvement
est intéressant on est passé en encours
à fin décembre 2010 9 2 689 2 milliards
d'euros à 891 3 milliards d'euros donc
la trésorerie des entreprises a augmenté
de 204 milliards d'euros sur l'année
dernière donc phénomènes parallèles qui
est assez remarquable et donc qui
illustre aussi quand même que la notion
d' encaisses de précaution basé sur le
pge a joué son plein dire et c'est
logique dans la gestion d'une entreprise
dans un dans une situation d'incertitude
eux aussi importante
néanmoins je crois que le point qu'il
faut qu'on partage ensemble et qui est
critique
d'une certaine façon c'est le taux
d'endettement des sociétés non
financières en france à l'issue de cette
opération
sauf si la trésorerie accumulée vient
pour désendetter rapidement mais on est
en dette brute en pourcentage du pib à
87 6% et là où je rappelle que les
entreprises allemandes représente 48% 48
23% 1 du pib pendant 50 % du pib en
dette brute et en dette nette
c'est là quand on fait la soustraction
de la trésorerie par rapport à
l'endettement global des entreprises
françaises on est quand même à 48 % du
pib 48,3 précisément là où l'allemagne
est à 30%
donc voilà le sujet aussi de l'agilité
en sortie de crise de nos entreprises
et ça c'est un sujet qu'il faut qu'on
regarde de très près au niveau macro et
comment va se rééquilibrer
le ratio trésorerie sur dette 1 à la
sortie dans la sortie de la crise avec
la question derrière de la trésorerie ça
serait bien aussi bien sûr qu'elles
servent à investir donc l'arbitrage
versus désendettement est un vrai sujet
aussi et donc ce qui ce qui me fait dire
au site les deux sujets pour notre pays
en sortie de crise les plus cruciaux
finalement c'est qu'on risque sortir
avec la double peine d'un endettement
massif d'entreprise et d'un endettement
massif de l'état et donc effectivement
la situation n'est pas au beau fixe mais
en moins alors je voudrais rebondir
aussi sur les prévisions
macroéconomiques parce que c'est un
facteur capital pour voit aussi comment
on va sortir la banque de france a déjà
communiqué là-dessus on est en train
d'actualiser nos calculs y compris
d'ailleurs je vais revenir sur les
questions de calcul d'inflation
notamment y compris au travers des
matières premières et de ce type de
facteurs les prévisions macroéconomiques
de croissance que nous faisons et que
nous harmonisons les autres pays de la
zone euro un bien sûr pour la politique
monétaire montre et ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle que toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
donc je rebondis sur une des précautions
que que vous avez mentionné dans vos
questions qui est qu'il faut pas que
nous ayons rebond pandémique mais
entendu parce que là on va rebattre les
cartes
les cartes sur la sur la capacité à
rebondir mais les prévisions de
croissance que nous avons arrêté montre
que nous devrions faire un record
historique si je puis dire depuis la fin
des trente glorieuses 5 5% de croissance
au moins on
1021 extraordinaire on n'a jamais fait
ça depuis plus de 30 ans sauf que c'est
de la récupération c'est pas du plus et
en 2022
nos analyses et nos économistes pensent
que nous devrions faire à peu près la
même chose 5%
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans
le courant du premier semestre 2010
peut-être même au démarrage de cette
année nous devrions avoir comblé le
creux terrible de l'année 2020 non à 10%
1 2 donc bien sûr de décroissance et qui
là aussi était un chiffre historiquement
bas par rapport à toute l'histoire
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale on
l'a déjà d'un registre et depuis années
de guerre donc voilà la situation donc
ce qui veut dire aussi que à court terme
et ensuite plus on s'éloigne plus c'est
compliqué bien sûr le présent l'avenir
je renforce une porte ouverte mais à
court terme sur sur les deux années sur
laquelle nous avons une visibilité
l'économie française
encore une fois toutes choses égales par
ailleurs devrait être capable de gérer
un rebond qui pourrait nous permettre
qu'il devrait nous permettre de digérer
le creux terrible de 2020 on reviendra à
l'état antérieur c'est ça que ça veut
dire
la croissance en valeur absolue ne sera
pas supérieure par rapport bien sûr aux
années pré crise alors je voulais aussi
rapidement reparler des caisses de la
question de comment accompagner le bfr
et est bon les sujets déjà sont tous
prêts participatifs ainsi tuto sur les
sur l'accompagnement du bfr pour les
entreprises les plus fragiles
nadal il joue pas et tout à l'heure qui
doit être étayé dans la suite dans les
prochains mois c'est que nous avons un
périmètre d'entreprise à risque en
termes de défaillances que nous estimons
à ce stade aux alentours de 13% des
entreprises
donc c'est pas non plus le raz-de-marée
sur l'ensemble l'économie donc il faut
être effectivement les gens mais ça ça
corrobore aussi le +5 25% de croissance
sur ces entreprises
clairement il est capital d'avoir la
capacité d'identifier à l'avance le
risque de défaillance et que tous les
acteurs se mobilisent pour les
accompagner ce qui veut dire que il faut
communiquer au maximum il faut les
identifier
alors on est en mesure de le faire coter
banque de france avec nos bases et on va
diffuser des listes ensuite et qu'on va
analyser dans le cadre des structures de
classe dont on parlait avec les préfet
avec l'ensemble des acteurs et bien sûr
la dg philippe et donc il faudra
certainement lot de vente ces
entreprises
et il faut aussi valoriser les
procédures de sauvegarde en temps parler
qui sont des procédures efficaces pour
quand des entreprises sont viables pour
leur permettre de passer le cap est
également aussi regarder les questions
de médiation on peut les prendre en
médiation avec par contre le cab ead qui
est que le surendettement ou l'excès
d'endettement supplémentaire pour ces
entreprises est souvent un facteur de
risque important
donc il faut aussi regarder je me
prononcerai pas sur l'abandon des pg e
ou là c'est un sujet politique et qui a
priori n'est pas l'ordre du jour je
voudrais aussi pour répondre à une
question sur la sinistralité dp jeu ça
va coûter combien aux contribuables si
je puis dire
nous avons fait les analystes alors
qu'ils ont qui ont bien sûr un certain
nombre de paramètres d'incertitude mais
le pourcentage de défaillance sur le
remboursement des pe eu égard au
contexte économique au profit
d'entreprises dont je parlais le
contexte le risque de sinistralité
devrait s'établir entre quatre et demi
et 6 % des entreprises ayant eu un pg e
ce qui veut dire que derrière ça engage
la responsabilité de l'état caution à
90% bien sûr de cp g20 donc le risque
pour les finances publiques a été
analysée avec bercy intégrée dans le
projet de loi de finances et c'est aussi
bien sûr pour ça que on a fait on a fait
tout ce calcul je vois venir aussi
rapidement sur le dispositif des prêts
participatifs
on a été interpellé j'ai vu aussi des
échanges avec la ceppm ce matin sur il
faut clarifier absolument ce que sont
ces prêts participatifs
est-ce que c'est l'instrument miracle
pour relancer la trésorerie la structure
financière l'entreprise
ces prêts participatifs il faut être
très clair ce ne sont pas des fonds
propres
ce ne sont pas les fonds propres ce sont
des prêts tant le conseil ne se la
comptabilité que l'administration
fiscale considère que ce sont des prêts
et nous dans notre cotation banque de
france on les considère comme des prix
au 6 mai mais et c'est là que le
dispositif est intéressant ce sont des
prêts subordonnés de long terme
sur huit ans avec un différé possible de
quatre ans ce qui fait que c'est un
instrument de dette particulièrement
favorable quand même pour aider les
entreprises et donc il est quand même
intéressant de promouvoir ce dispositif
et je rebondis sur ce que disait crise
au bo selon le profil de l'entreprise
aussi un il faut voir quels profits nice
à l'entreprise mais c'est un dispositif
intéressant étant une dette subordonnée
ça donne quand même eu un confort
extrême important à l'entreprise alors
plus en question
je signale aussi que la banque de france
dans sa cotation
parce que là on a une influence
importante ensuite sur les décideurs et
notamment sur les banques poursuivent
les entreprises dans notre cotation
entre en compte ces ppr ces prêts
participatifs relance de façon favorable
cerrada graff pas si je puis dire où ça
ne pond des repas la notation qu'on peut
donner l'entreprise la même manière
qu'une dette classique 1 donc ça permet
aussi de valoriser ce type de ce type de
produits sur l'opportunité l'opportunité
de re localiser emplois en france
là on est dans un grand débat qui est un
débat sociétal quasiment un don qui
dépasse bien sûr les compétences de la
banque de france
ce que je peux dire simplement voulais
partager ça avec vous c'est que le
projet france relance avec le dispositif
qui est mis en place par l'état est un
dispositif qui permet de soutenir
justement ce type de relocalisation et
c'est éminemment souhaitable
on parlait tout à l'heure du commerce
extérieur l'enjeu bien entendu dans la
sortie de crise et de rééquilibrer nos
comptes extérieurs qui sont bien sûr
comme vous le savez mis à mal encore
plus avec la crise le dernier point dont
je vais peut-être par les cetc la hausse
du coût des matières premières et les
prévisions d'inflation
c'est très important aussi y compris sur
l'effet d'entraînement possible sur le
taux d'intérêt derrière et donc ça ça
fait partie aussi du package d'aidés
élément absolument cruciaux pour
construire une bonne sortie de crise
nous sommes en train de recalculer alors
de manière coordonnée dans le cas de
leur système avec toutes les autres
banques centrales puisque la politique
monétaire est unique
le taux de les prévisions de taux date
des prisons d'inflation pour pour les
prochains mois et
et donc on les publiera le 13 juin
normalement donc j'ai pas de scoop a
donné là dessus pour l'instant si ce
n'est que notre perception à ce stade
mais les calculs sont encore il faut
qu'on les et hey c'est que les faits
assez lourd que nous remonte tous les
chefs d'entreprise au beaucoup sur
l'impact des matières premières et sur
les ruptures d'approvisionnement
également lié aux chaînes export qui
sont vrais aux chaînes internationales
pardon d'approvisionnement qui sont
longues
cet impact là on pense qu'il serait
plutôt transitoire ça qu'on n'est pas
dans du structurel du moyen ou du long
terme qui auront un impact de long terme
sur l'inflation mais en moins ça veut
pas dire que ça ne sera pas un facteur
important d'impact sur la structure
financée entreprises dans le court terme
c'est à dire c'est un c'est un des
facteurs qui complexifie le rebond et la
croissance des 5 25% dont je parlais
mais on l'a intégré dans ce calcul de
croissance voilà donc ça c'est aussi un
point important et donc les prévisions
d'inflation elle son capital parce que
derrière il ya toute la stratégie taux
d'intérêt et donc des financements des
économies dans leur système
les prisons de la façon dont on en
reparlera le 13 juin
en ce corps donnera bien sûr que
d'autres banques centrales au système et
donc notre notre visibilité là dessus
est une visibilité qui est plutôt
raisonnable
voilà mais pour l'instant j'attends que
les économistes et a terminé les calculs
merci monsieur le directeur
il y aurait une question mais peut-être
trouvé un petit retour écrit là-dessus
ou plus que reprendre la parole sur la
question de yat-il finalement une part
d'économie perdu à l'issue du cycle oui
non ou y at il un espoir d'avoir un
surplus de croissance encore par exemple
en 2022 que celles qui permettraient de
remonter à scorer et et l'économie sans
la crise laisse un point plus
intellectuel et un peu économique quand
même chez nous un petit peu et qui nous
intéresse mais si vous pouvez nous nous
donner quelques éléments là dessus bien
monsieur on va terminer donc par le
directeur général des finances publiques
qui va reprendre les points qu'ils
souhaitent reprendre et bien sûr qu'il
va aussi s'appuyer sur ce qui a déjà été
traité pour compléter les réponses merci
monsieur le directeur
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vais essayer de reprendre peut-être
d'ailleurs un peu par pardon par la fin
des sujets accompagnement des
entreprises publicité à faire autour de
du dispositif tel qu'il a été annoncé la
semaine passée à huy il ya bien sûr un
plan de déploiement de communication
auprès des entreprises
l'idée c'est enfin on est en juin
les choses vont se mettre
progressivement on a tous dit on voit
pas de mur de dettes on voit peut-être
déboulait dans la durée mais pas de mur
au sens propre
donc on a aussi un peu de temps et ça
sert à rien je dirais de faire un grand
plan de communication juste avant l'été
et puis ensuite que tout le monde six
mois plus tard dans l'euphorie de la
croissance n'est oublié donc voilà on va
essayer d'égrainer le dispositif
un point important que la courage
pointer les sujets et monsieur le
président et d'autres que vous pointez
les sujets de deux dispositifs d'
analyse il faut bien visualiser que
les dispositifs qu'ils soient banque de
france urssaf ou qu'ils soient des fip
qui sont et qu'on fait converger dans un
même modèle il vise à de la détection
mais on est dans une situation
extrêmement difficile d or nous mêmes on
avait un modèle de détection de
vulnérabilités ont fait du recouvrement
donc on cherche à savoir si des
entreprises sont une érable ou pas et
pendant la crise on a été obligé de le
modifier ce modèle parce que la réalité
y compris la temporalité de ses modèles
et des algorithmes car ils sont
absolument pas adaptée à une situation
dans lequel je dirais il y avait un
commerce fermé pendant six mois
donc on a cherché à les adapter pendant
la crise on cherche maintenant à les
rendre plus forts et avec l'ensemble des
données mais ils ne représenteront faut
bien ce pas se tromper là dessus ils ne
représenteront qu'une partie de
l'information qui nous arrivera on ne se
répondent se focalisera pas
exclusivement sur des algorithmes pour
savoir les entreprises vulnérables
on a un dispositif y compris des coûte
avec un téléphone recevait plusieurs
milliers d'appels chaque jour
d'entrepreneurs sur notre dispositif
d'appel pour les orienter vers les
dispositifs mis en place par l'état le
pedn les prêts participatifs
le fonds de solidarité on va laisser en
place et le faire migrer vers
l'accompagnement vers les solutions de
sortie de crise et d'une certaine
manière tout ce qui a été fait au niveau
ce qui se met en place au niveau local
avec le comité départemental a sortie de
crise
il vit aussi à ce que l'ensemble des
acteurs puisse dire est joué les grandes
oreilles vert
les les décisions à prendre en
distinguant bien monsieur le rapporteur
général et bien un point très important
pour nous en distinguant bien ce qui est
de la participation collective à cet
effort d'accompagnement des entreprises
et de visualisation des difficultés
micro sectorielle local d'entreprise
particulière et ce qui est traitement in
fine et orientations traitements y
compris dans des conditions de
confidentialité qui vont être
nécessaires si on veut naturellement que
l'entreprise se trouvent vos livres et
au vu et au su de tous ses créanciers
comme étant reconnu comme en difficulté
parce que là pour le coup on est à peu
près sûr du résultat et on la mettrait
dans une grande grande difficulté donc
il faut on a ce chaînage l'a totalement
en tête
naturellement il fera l'objet d'une
attention soutenue mais c'est bien un
point particulier sur le sujet des pg e
et k a dit beaucoup de choses et 130
milliards 1,2 de décaisser sur l'
enveloppe de 35 milliards qui a été une
mise au départ on l'a mis d'ailleurs
effectivement dans les comptes généraux
de l'état à fin 2020 et on a retenu dans
les comptes général dans le compte
général de l'état un taux de défaillance
de 5,25 qui a à peu près le poids moyens
entre les deux bornes que si tu es avec
la courage en disant voilà c'est notre
estimation de ce que peut être
voilà sachant qu'il ya ensuite derrière
un partage effectivement entre les
banques et l'état
un point qui est important sur les
sujets participatif et
en complément de ce qui a été dit nous
on a une vision où on essaie de ne pas
trop mélanger les instruments et d'une
certaine manière à un moment donné il ya
des instruments en fonds propres mais ça
existe il y en a plein et on a des
banques publiques qui appuient y compris
en fonds propres les entreprises
on a des instruments de dette ce qui ont
été développés pour la crise et on a des
instruments de quasi fonds propres
ils font un peu la jonction l'objectif à
la fin c'est pas que l'état se retrouve
au capital de l'ensemble des acteurs
publics et d'ailleurs dans le système y
compris du fonds de transition qui est
mise en place de 3 milliard d'euros ou y
aura pareil plus un instrument à
l'intérieur la logique c'est d'avoir y
compris dans les prêts participatifs des
lic où on organise d'une certaine
manière un retrait progressif c'est à
dire y compris avec un taux d'intérêt
qui est par exemple être croissant dans
le temps pour faire en sorte que
l'entreprise et intérêts à un moment
donné à sortir et à retrouver des
conditions de financement normales ne
m'aide pas rester dans un système qui
est un système je dirais parapublic de
financement de l'économie
point important ça a été dit sur le
carry back j'y reviens pas un point qui
est qui et marquant nous on a été assez
et ça a été vrai sur des dispositifs de
carry-back ça a été vrai sur les
dispositifs de dettes fiscales
on avait quand même ouvert très très
largement le dispositif in fine et un
peu moins vrai sur les dettes sociales
mais c'est très net sur les dettes
fiscales
beaucoup d'entreprises se sont remis en
régularité par rapport à leurs créances
fiscales à dire qu'elles n'ont pas du
tout abusé du système
au contraire elles ont essayé de se
remettre dans une trajectoire qui est la
trajectoire normale de fonctionnement
d'une entreprise solvables et équipe qui
est capable de fonctionner et ça je
dirais c'est d'abord c'est un motif je
dirais de limiter l'inquiétude par
rapport à l'effet boulet qu'on pourrait
pressentir y compris par rapport à tes
soldats ces sujets là les ans de
trésorerie globale sans doute se
retrouvent aussi là mais c'est un point
important qu'il ne faut pas sous-estimer
donc la logique des sujets d'annulation
aujourd'hui ne nous paraît absolument
pas justifié ça veut pas dire que dans
une situation particulière et
aujourd'hui c'est le cas d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui se passe quand une
entreprise est en très grande difficulté
qu'elle passe dans une procédure
collective et qu'il y à une
restructuration de dette dans le cadre
de ce type de procédure donc pas dans
celle je dirais qu'on essaye de
promouvoir un peu en amont et plus en en
conciliation en préventif mais dans des
procédures de redressement
naturellement l'ensemble des créanciers
sont appelés c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il ya justement une commission des
chefs de services financiers au niveau
local présidé par le directeur
départemental des finances publiques qui
vise justement à voir jusqu'où on va
dans l'abandon de dette et on travaille
suivant la taille des entreprises soit
au niveau local soit en partenariat avec
le ciri naturellement au niveau central
lorsque on est sur des entreprises de
taille importante donc il ya bien le
dispositif qui existe mais il doit être
adapté à lirey des situations dans
lequel au fond il faut effectivement que
les créanciers met à la poche
parce que il n'y a pas d'autre solution
pour faire redémarrer l'entreprise et là
il faut pas qu'on se trompe il faut pas
qu'on sauve des entreprises qui
objectivement n'aurait pas vocation à
être sauvée et il faut que nos
dispositifs c'est toute la difficulté
d'orienter sur les bons dispositif qu'on
arrive à soutenir les entreprises qui
objectivement ont été impactés
négativement par la crise mais sont
prêtes à redémarrer et sont bien sûr non
des business plans qui sont favorables
je reviens pas sur ce qu'a dit très bien
christophe on a déjà des mesures
fiscales de baisse de l'impôt et finir
elles sont là et on les a pas remise en
cause et la baisse du taux de liesse
ça répond aussi pas de hausse d'impôt en
réalité on fait des baisses d'impôts et
donc on continue à aider et à soutenir
l'économie
d'ailleurs ménages comme entreprises
dans les dispositifs fiscaux et qui ont
été déjà voté par le parlement
et de ce point de vue là je crois qu'on
est totalement dans cet appui et je le
disais on a beaucoup d'autres
dispositifs ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille
à ce stade en tout cas en rajouter c'est
un point et peut-être que je conclurai
part par là c'est que au fond on a à
travers le plan de relance a été évoquée
il a aussi beaucoup d'appuis y compris
je dirai au développement et à
l'investissement et à l'innovation des
entreprises ou dans un certain nombre de
secteurs à travers les dispositifs de
baisse de la fiscalité
on a déjà énormément de choses en place
donc je pense qu'il faut un
plusieurs intervenants l'ont dit mais
effectivement s'appuyer sur la confiance
parce qu'objectivement sait si elle est
là virey faut surtout pas s'en priver
pas se priver de l'entretenir de sans
doute être à la fois lucide sur la
situation y compris d'endettement global
l'un des acteurs privés et publics c'est
pas parce qu'on est confiant qu'on n'est
pas lucide sur cette situation elle est
une situation d'endettement à
exceptionnel on a rarement connu et 3
sans doute ne pas se précipiter
totalement y compris sur des sujets un
peu pointu de se dire je fais de la
dentelle avant même de savoir quel est
le problème est d'une certaine manière
je le disais sur les instruments on
essaye de garder des logiques
d'instruments un peu spécifique face à
différents types de situation
l'intention n'est pas non plus d'entrer
dans le micro fonctionnement ou dans le
fonctionnement micro économique de
l'entreprise pour se dire là il ya un
problème de stocks là il ya un problème
de dette fournisseurs là il ya un
problème et je mets un à chaque fois un
mode de financement particulier je pense
qu on a plutôt intérêt à faire confiance
à nos acteurs économiques et ensuite
effectivement espérer que on retrouve
les couleurs et au delà des couleurs
qu'on a perdu à l'occasion de la crise
merci chez elle et enchaînera merci à
vous tous messieurs pour la qualité de
la présentation d'abord de vos réponses
ensuite
[Musique]